Can I set my category here real quick?
Oops.
Where's the category button? I never do
this because I always reream, but I want
to make sure that this one gets plenty
of attention.
This is the stream, folks. This is the
stream.
I add Where's the categories?
Nope.
Tags. There it is.
What's the category that people use for
this?
Hey folks. Yep. I'm just getting the
stream set up. I will go over the basics
in just a moment of what we're doing
today. Uh this is the stream everybody's
been asking me for though.
Hang on. Hang on. We will
we will uh we'll talk about bias and all
that stuff in a second. Let me at least
get this thing set up. What's the
category called again for uh
programming?
Software and game development. There it
is.
Okay, good. I just wanted to add that
today. Um, I wanted to add that today so
that we would be extra sure that people
see it.
Okay,
that will be an act of confirmation by
Okay, so here, let me address all this
stuff, right?
I'm going to post that we're live on on
Twitter. I'm going to go over the ground
rules for this. This will be a full day
stream. Um, unless things are very clear
one way or the other quite quickly.
Okay, cool.
So, we got some people. Now, let me lay
some ground rules for this, okay? And
let me give a little bit of context.
Literally since GPT 3.5 came out, I have
been dealing with people telling me that
these models write really good code and
you shouldn't be writing all your code
by hand and you should be using these mo
like these models and if you're not
using these models then you must just be
a bad programmer. I like the number of
things I've heard has been ridiculous
and this has gone back to 3.5. Now the
thing is back then the people saying
this were just objectively all terrible
programmers who had no idea what they
were doing anyways and like some of the
better known people were researchers who
were good scientists but who are just
terrible programmers right so nobody
really took that seriously but recently
as the models have gotten better we
started to sort of collect more people
who are uh better known and in
particular you know we got that tweet
from car path lately saying that
actually these models are very good and
I feel very far behind. I have no idea
what he's on about. We've gotten some
stuff from George Hops. It's a little
bit more moderate, believe it or not.
Um, but it's not like Universal or
anything. There's still a bunch of very
good programmers online that are
basically saying the same exact thing
that I have. But since we actually are
starting to get some people that have a
lot of reach and that have a very good
reputation for their work, um I wanted
to see what this was all about and give
it a very fair test. So despite the fact
that you've seen me saying publicly that
I expect this to fail terribly, I'm
actually setting it up the opposite.
Right? I'm a scientist. I am trained as
a scientist. I'm not going to set up my
experiment to get the result that I
want. No, I'm actually going to do the
opposite, you know, in order to
counteract that bias. So, here's the
deal. We're building an environment
today. Okay, an environment is a
standalone single file application,
right? They're like, uh, let me show you
for the newcomers around here.
This is the main project I developed.
This is Puffer AI. This is the highest
performance reinforcement learning
project out there. We're training at
millions of steps per second, targeting
10 million in the next release. All open
source. Start the project to help the
pluffer. It's free. Um, here are some of
our environments, right? They range from
everything like very simple games to
substantially more complicated stuff.
This is like an excavation simulation.
We've got Go in here. We've got drones.
We've got this autonomous driving sim.
We actually have a new version of this
uh in collab with NYU. We've got a lot
of stuff. These are all open source. We
use these to power all of our research.
Okay. Um, and the way that these are
developed should be ideal for language
models because I make all of these very
simple. Most of these environments are
developed in a single file. Uh, they
have no dependencies other than ray for
rendering which is one of the most
popular projects out there. There's tons
of good documentation. like the models
already should know everything about uh
the API of that library from scratch
without me even having to tell it
anything. Uh you do not really have to
hook into Puffer at all. Like it's just
a spec that you name this function this
and it takes these args. Like it's a
very very loose API essentially. It's a
convention more than anything. Uh it's
very very easy to match and I have tons
of examples for this. Okay. And the code
is very concise. Like even this, this is
our probably my most complex
environment. This is a full MMO. This
thing has an exchange. It has leveling.
It has items. It has weapons. This
thing's like 2 3,000 lines of code.
Okay. So, these are very compact and
they're very fast. So, this should be an
ideal C test is writing a new
environment. Now, I'm not going to give
it something like Breakout, right?
Because like obviously there are so many
copies of Breakout out there that the
code is just there. And heck, I even
have my own code reference for this. So,
if I give it a similar arcade game to
this, yeah, I wouldn't be surprised if
you can get something pretty quick out
of this. Sure. But that's not super
super useful on its own, right? What
we're going to aim for is a medium
complexity environment today. Something
like maybe this or this. Something that
is maybe a thousand lines of codeish.
All right, that is going to be the
target.
And I will discuss the task. Let me just
address one a couple other things before
I describe the actual task we're going
to implement. Um hype, I've gone through
this extensively on X. Plenty of people
say Opus is fine. Carpathy and um uh
George Hotz were both on this one. Like
if you're going to get to the point
where we're splitting hairs over is it
Opus versus the other latest model and
like actually if you're not using my
favorite model from the last couple
months, like I'm not taking that
seriously. All right. Like I will take
seriously a lot of feedback today. And
actually the goal of streaming this and
announcing this is I want actually I
want to make sure that if I'm using the
model wrong or doing something weird, I
want everybody to be giving me feedback.
And I will take most of that feedback
seriously.
Unless people do stuff that like I can't
I obviously can't even test. Um or you
know like oh you need to go spend six
months studying prompting or some like
utterly ridiculous stuff. Right? For the
most part, I'm going this is going to
actually be a best effort to make the
model work.
Okay. So, the actual environment that
we're implementing. Do we have any
Runescape fans on here?
This is the environment that I'm
implementing today. So, this is the
final boss of the first raid. uh
released in old school Runescape.
Uh this game inspired my PhD. It
inspired a lot of my research. It's a
really really well-designed game for use
with AI. And uh we're not going to go
try to implement an entire MMO today.
That would be ridiculous. But what I was
going to do is I was going to see can we
come up with like a simplified uh as
close as possible standalone simulator
for this one fight.
And it's kind of cool because there are
some strategies that you can use in this
fight that let you take no damage. Uh
it's very well understood. I personally
know exactly how it works as well. And
it's like not nothing. Like look, this
is the the stuff that can happen in it,
but it's not a huge amount. I think we
can do something like this pretty
similar in maybe a thousand dish lines
of code.
This is what the fight looks like.
This sound like a cool environment? I
think this sounds like a cool
environment.
Now, the thing is I don't actually
expect that we're going to have a cool
environment by the end of today because
I don't think it's going to work. But
like I since people are saying, oh, you
know, this confirmation bias, you don't
want it to work. I decided to pick a
really cool problem that I would be very
excited if we got something to work by
the end of today to balance it out.
Okay. And yes, Ben, there will be a blog
post unless the results are just like
entirely unexiting or whatever or
middling or whatever. There will be
something
cool.
Okay, cool. Add rate. We're not doing
ray tracing, man. We're not going to
like say, "Oh, it can't implement ray
tracing, so it's bad." Heck, we're not
even going to try to do the full render
for this. Like the main thing is I want
something that looks recognizable to
this bite where um there's like this
cycle mechanic where if you hit it at a
specific time and then move and then hit
it like there's this cycle mechanic
where you can take no damage if we're
able to actually get it so that you can
have that be the case that would be
pretty cool and you know we can get an
agent to learn it. So this will be
implemented as a single file in puffer
lib. Um you know we should be able to
train agents. I actually expect this to
be a very easy task. Like any one fight
out of an MMO is very very easy to
learn. You know it's the bigger
exploration of an MMO that is hard. Uh
we're not going to do like equipment
simulator or anything. So I think we can
do this in about a thousand lines.
How to reduce this rate into an MVP. No,
that is not and that's not how RL works
either. Um, is the code from this fight
out in the open? No, this will be from
scratch. But again, like this is should
only be about a thousand lines of code.
I can ignore all these mechanics to
start with and just do the basic attacks
and then do these later. Frankly, I'll
be surprised if we even get something
decent with basic attacks in out of um a
language model. So now here's the thing.
We've got we've now got almost 40 people
watching already. So, uh, I want to I
want to allow the viewers to decide a
few things. Microphone audio is a bit
scuff. Really shouldn't be. This is not
my $800 mic. This is my $200 mic. Um,
you can let me know if this is better. I
might be just clipping it as well. Let
me turn it down a little bit.
All right. You can let me know on that.
So, uh, since we have a bunch of people
watching, the first thing I want to let
you guys decide
is, uh, for the first chunk of this,
should I edit code manually?
Would you rather that I spend the first
bit of time trying to get this thing to
write all the code with a precise spec,
or should I from the start also be
editing the code manually?
And I will write a very precise spec.
Keep in mind I write specs for RL
environments professionally because I
then implement those environments.
Right? This is how we do our contract
work.
Love your thought on the right amount to
use these models. I suspect it may be
close to zero. That is my my current is
very close to zero. column
vibe it only prompting try without first
precise spec spec first okay so
okay we will do a precise spec and if
that doesn't work we will go in to try
to do it manually so I'm not going to
say that it has to do everything or it's
worthless um
I think that we will also be very we
will be very disciplined about the code
quality because if I have to edit it
later it has to produce something that I
can actually edit that is good Right.
So,
I wish I could show you guys one of the
specs that I've written. Um, I can't
because they're for clients, but the way
that we do our work with Puffer
professionally, I build high performance
RL SIMs for companies. And part of that
is a formal scoping process in which we
write a precise spec of everything that
needs to be delivered. And, you know, if
I'm imprecise in my spec, I get hurt
down the line because then I end up
having to do more work. So, uh, I don't
like it's not like I know I've been
prompting LLMs a bunch, but I know how
to write a precise spec for this exact
type of problem. So, I think that's what
we're going to start with. Um,
apparently the coolest programming
language for these vibe people is
English. So, we'll do that. And I think
that at the very least we will produce
something that is more precise and
better than any of these people using
the models would do in this in this
case. So I have the advantage here in
that because I have the domain
familiarity uh I don't think anybody
will be able to write a better spec for
this than I can.
What is the plan for this stream? We're
implementing this fight with Opus. That
is the plan. And we're basically
evaluating whether this model is any
good. Um and whether all of this like
basically all the heavy LLM workflows
are any good or if these people are
nuts.
I wouldn't be too up on it initi I do
not expect this to work. I hope it works
but I don't expect it will work.
There'll be a fun article out of it
either way.
I will give it uh I will give it the
let's see actually we will allow
everybody to get context. So I just got
this thing set up. You can see this is
my local machine.
All right. We've got a GPU on it. Uh, I
have the ability to render whatever
environment I want from Puffer.
uh, this now has access to context from
this entire repo, right? So, I don't
have to paste in text. I can just direct
it to files, right?
The first thing I'm going to do, I'm not
going to manually write code, but I am
going to give it a I'm going to give it
a leg up.
Okay. So here this is the target
environment which is a simple multi-
aent environment that has a commented
template. All right. This is going to
use this its best editor. I do not no no
you can't be saying that I have to use
VS code for this. There's the model
operates the exact same way from uh it
can read my files either way. Right.
There's like no difference between if
I'm editing in VS Code or if I'm editing
in my command line in Vim and stuff,
right? There's no difference from the
perspective of the model.
Have you written any skills?
No. And from what I saw, these are just
prompts anyways. I will take feedback
from everybody here. Okay? There will be
feedback avail.
You have to let me get started a little
bit though. Activate thinking.
Uh, is there a separate thinking mode
that you have to activate for opus? I
set it to opus here. Is there a thinking
mode I have to activate?
Llinter. I don't even use the llinter
normally, dude.
And now he's doing it wrong. Well, this
is the point, Benjamin. This is why I'm
streaming it and why I advertised it and
why I'm going to be taking feedback.
Most of the hype is literally cloud
code. Okay, that's what I expected. If
there's a thinking mode I need to
activate or some other setting, let me
know. But we're going to start with
spec text.
uh, does this thing have web built in or
do I need to copy paste the text of the
wiki article?
You have to add Ultraink to your prompt.
Is that actually a thing? Can anybody
confirm that?
What's this? Is this a global prompt
major?
Yeah. Okay. So, this is like compressed
dots.
Actually, again, when I said I would
give this the best possible case, uh I
think ours is even easier. Okay, ours
should be even easier for Claude because
we don't have all this stuff. It's
literally a standalone file.
Well, I look this is not done. This is
one line. We have to write a full doc.
What auto suggest do I use? I just use
uh super maven which is a really dumb
fast model. That's all I use.
Ultra think is a valid suggestion. You
can set it globally. Cool.
So init
then change it
do slashinit for something like this. So
just like
all right what does this thing think
it's doing?
Oh it thinks that it's making its own
docs.
Ignore most tips. It has tools. Well, I
will make sure I don't screw it over by
like in like limiting it in some way.
Yes, you can cat a file.
Fine.
Let's start on the spec in the meantime
so we can see what I'm going to do here.
Cloud code best practices.
They mention how thinking works there.
Cool. Let's let me get the spec started
first because otherwise we're going to
take forever. Um and we need to write a
spec for this either way. Yes.
This is this is super maven just like
autocompleting silly stuff. By the way,
um I'm not going to be using this for
this spec. I'm just going to type
Whoops.
I forgot this is not a command line.
Someone is cutting you off in
conversation
for non code. Yeah. Yeah. Uh
where is it? Maybe
Let's get in context and try to
summarize.
If anybody if people confirm that, I
will use something else.
But
I swear if like it's just some dumb
rumor and then people are like, "Oh
yeah, they nerfed is not good anymore,
bro. I'm going to lose my [ __ ]
Okay, so this is just some basics.
Um, let us give it
we should give it let's just give it the
text of the wiki article.
Does it have some does it have some
built-in web search or not at all guys?
Actually, why don't we just ignore the
stats except for
we will just ignore the stats except for
hit points and um we'll just give it
like fixed damage values so that it
doesn't have to like go find damage
formulas. Okay, we're going to make this
really really easy.
Oh, it'll scrape it.
We try to oneshot it. I'm obviously
going to guide it. I'm not going to go
like, "Oh, it can't implement this in
one prompt. It's dumb." Like, again,
this is not I'm not setting it up to
fail. I'm setting it up to succeed as
best as I possibly can, right?
Give it a link to the wiki. Better. Yep,
there it is. There's your link.
Exact head turning behavior.
Make sure you have run plan mode and
tell it to ask you questions.
If others will confirm that I will.
adding constraints so it doesn't go
nuts. Yeah, I'm going to add
constraints.
You paste the spec
and make into chat. You make into a chat
and then we can try alongside you.
Uh, sure.
First to plan using plan mode before
asking it to write code. Okay, we will
do we will do that. You all can guide me
through that
with shift tab twice.
Okay, cool.
What class will the player be? There are
no classes in Runescape, my dude.
This is I picked this task specifically
because I figured that this is one where
like obviously I want this environment
because it's awesome. Um,
I have probably more experience than
anybody else on specking out and writing
RL environments and like game RL
environments especially like this. And
I've also done this fight like 700 times
before I stopped playing.
So,
I figured that like this would be
overall the best possible thing to pick.
Range melee. You need both for this
fight, dude. All
Where's the turning mechanic? I need to
know the exact ticks.
Am
I late to the part? What's the
consensus? We just started, man. You're
not late. We're just starting
live for 30 minutes. We got some stuff
set up and we're starting to write a
spec for this. Hey, Jess.
Uh, actually, I'll do Ted turning last
because this is the only complicated
mechanic.
what was the prob what's the probability
that it switches?
Oh, it's 1/5. There it is.
What have you missed? Not much. We're
starting to write a spec for this. I've
announced the task that we're working
on. It is this ridiculous fight.
So it's uh
what is this? Left claw.
This the right one is mage, right? It's
left on the screen. Yeah.
Yeah, actually I already have that in
the damage values. It's fine.
Yeah.
So, uh, beep bop, my my PhD is on like
the use of MMOs and what we can learn
from them for RL. And a lot of the
infrastructure that I've built kind of
leverages uh techniques from game
development or uh large scale games in
the '9s in order to write really fast
environments.
Uh what is it? Use use a trident on long
range, right?
Is it on long? No, it's not on long
Come on. There there are enough people
watching. We've got to have uh one
player. What's the attack range from
which like you're supposed to hit this?
Is it eight tiles or 10 tiles?
Whatever. We'll get the details
as we go.
I have not done this fight in a few
years, but I have done this fight a lot.
Uh, I'm trying to remember what is the
takes a particularly heavy hit. We'll
ignore this clunch thing.
Does it say how long you have? Um, I
forget how many ticks it is that you
have
to uh
to kill the uh the hands next to each
other
and actually we'll put the HP values in
as well. 600 600.
Doesn't creating MS manually seem like a
dead end which hits the scaling wall.
Hundreds of thousands of tasks.
This is a completely different case, my
dude.
We train models that are like I train
models that are between 100,000 and a
few million parameters and I train them
like sometimes a 100,000 times real time
on a single GPU.
The LLM bros are like training these
massive models on essentially no data.
The task that you would apply these two
things are completely different as well.
Like you will never solve these tasks
with a language model like the ones that
we do and you will never solve the types
of text tasks with the stuff that we do,
right?
Where's that annotation with um there
should be a picture of this thing. So,
the important thing about this fight
that I thought would be really cool to
model is the head turns towards you and
uh there's like a pattern on the floor
where if you're standing on specific
tiles, you can turn the head and then
not get hit.
It's very cool.
You're still using TDLearning.
uh we're using a variant of PO
that has
it has a bootstrap that's kind of based
on TD but just saying oh you're using TD
learning is not really right at all.
Yeah, for reference since we have a lot
of people here. Um, look, the stuff that
I do, it's on Puffer AI. We have all
these M's. They all run in your browser.
The agents are actually running in your
browser, too, because they're tiny.
Like, good luck scoring a single point
on on this dude. They're pretty good.
Um,
and oh yeah, if you want to help me for
free, just star the repo. Like, feed the
puff for a star. It helps me a lot. This
is kind of a one-off special stream, but
I actually I stream all of my
development on this project. We're
currently doing uh CUDA kernel
optimizations for the new release. We're
at 7 million steps per second. We're
doing a new architecture dev that's more
parallel. Uh we've got a whole bunch of
fancy things coming out in this next
release.
Okay, back to this though. Uh where's
the the picture?
Yeah, there it is.
This one.
Five tiles. Four tiles. I'm going to
guess and we'll fix it if it's wrong.
Why don't you have an ad blocker on? I
don't know, dude. This is I just got
this new desktop.
Um I have a bunch of machines. I haven't
bothered setting stuff up
even in the correct category. This time
we are
cannot see a player.
How many tiles is the map here?
The old map
is it? It's five on each side, right?
And then like
one, two, three,
six,
At least one of the people here has got
to be with my audience. We've at least
got to have one of the people here is
like logged in on this and just like
we'll check it or something.
Do you wish you had current models when
you're doing my PhD? No. That's the
thing, right? like they I have not found
them useful, which is why we're doing
this stream cuz everybody keeps telling
me that these models are so great and
we're going to find out.
Why don't I You ask it to write the
spec.
That would be very ambitious because if
I ask it to write the spec, then there's
no way in hell it's going to work.
I'm at least trying to make it work,
man.
I mean, I literally write specs for RL
environments professionally and then I
implement them myself by hand.
5x5.
What are we doing? This is the Opus
stream that everybody's asked for. So,
we are implementing this fight with
Opus.
We're starting by implementing a good
spec for this. Um,
we're going to ignore the specials to
start with and just try to get this head
turning behavior, which is the main key
of the fight. And, uh, we're going to
see if Opus can just generate all the
code with me telling it to fix things.
Uh, if that doesn't work, then we'll go
to me also being allowed to manually
edit and fix things. And we're going to
be taking feedback from chat the whole
time so that nobody can possibly say I'm
doing it wrong.
What's your guess in spending for this?
I have no idea. If it costs a few
hundred bucks for this stream, I don't
really care.
This is only a thousand lines of code.
Like, I can do this thing in a thousand
lines of code if I were doing it.
I think that this is
like 23
API token I have I just like set up with
API I don't like it doesn't matter to me
to like go that doesn't matter dude do
you have specs for previous M's
So I do Eigor, but the thing is that the
specs that I write, so I write those
professionally. Those are for clients.
So I can't like use one of those on the
stream for this, right?
Have you made any rubrics to assess and
evaluate? Well, it's does it get us an
environment, man? Like can we play it?
Can I train on it? Is the code like
usable? Right.
It's not that complicated. It's a single
It's going to be a single file
environment.
You know, I figured that this would be a
good environment because like it's
fairly complicated, but it's one that
I've like I have I know a lot about and
it's like relatively easy to see what if
it's working correctly or not. um even
if you have not played this thing and
it's like self very self-contained
single environment right things like
that
let me see what else we want to add to
this spec okay so
Let me think what environments I want to
give it as an example.
Uh, which ones which ones am I
particularly proud of the code quality
on?
but I want to give it something that's
tilebased.
No, maybe I will just give it neural
mammoth. It's basically the same system.
Give it docs website.
I'm giving it the template end for sure.
start implementing after written you're
going to refine loop and plan. Uh I'm
going to listen to the chat and do
whatever you all want me to do for that.
So probably since me most multiple
people have asked it, we're probably
going to do planning.
Puffer was probably in the training
data. Exactly. So like this is literally
the easiest possible thing I could give
it for a non-trivial task. Right. Like
it would be way harder for me to get
anything out of this if I were doing
core development. All right. Core
development on Puffer is really hard.
step by step. I am going to
I am going to
I'm not going to just say make the env
right like I mean if you guys think I
can say make the env I can try it's a
joke but I I like I want to actually
give this a chance to work. So my goal
here is to like take the advice of the
people who are like say, "Oh yeah, no, I
was a good programmer before, right? I'm
actually using this stuff seriously.
This is how I use the tools." Not just
like the people who couldn't program
before and now we're saying, "Yeah, I
can just make whatever I want. I just
sell it tell it to implement the code
and it works, right?"
Oh, yeah. Totally, Ben. But the thing
is, we don't have to care about those
people because those people are
obviously worthless, right?
I'm going to say Neural Mimone 3 and
Snake because they're both tile based.
It's pretty bad, but I also know nothing
about RL. Yeah. So, this is Robin. This
is one of the things that drives me
nuts. Instead of asking the LLM
questions about Puffer, like read the
docs and go through our tutorials. Like
I spent time making good resources so
you can learn it, right?
Don't ask the dumb LLM.
Ask the code to explore codebase before
you begin and to summarize it. Uh I
think it did that.
We're we're going to check what it
output.
Okay. References
trying to think how we do this.
Checkpoints for the agent to update.
What?
Ask questions on Discord. I like to test
LMS and how useful they are. Not a lot.
Yeah, I mean the best thing you can do
is just do some projects
with Puffer.
It's all open source. We try to make it
easier each update. Um I wish I could be
a lot more active in the Discord
answering questions all the time, Robin,
but like frankly the latest dev on 40 is
just really hard. Uh and I'm also
balancing it with client work. So like
most of the time you see me just like do
a long stream on 40 and then crash.
How is Opus different from Cloud Code?
It is the best model available in cloud
code
and let's see how I want to make sure we
do something to get reasonable code
quality out of
uh llm. What's this
do to Tim? Best ways to ask it to run a
llinter if it needs a verification step.
We will get to that for sure. Um, we
have I will give it the command to build
the environment so it can test.
What's set 1M?
Why would I need 1 mil?
Uh, it's this is going to be like a
thousand line environment just tops and
it doesn't have any depths.
Produce an incremental plan. Let's what
we're going to do. Here's the here's the
idea, guys. I'm going to write this for
however long it takes us to finish this.
We're like we have a decent start on
this. Um then we're all going to we will
I will like open this up and say hey
guys do you think this is a good initial
spec and you know anything that you
think oh you know we should add this we
should do this whatever we can do
we'll go through this process of having
it plan and do whatever the way that you
guys say. So, I'm I'm basically going to
leave a lot of it up to you guys so that
nobody is possibly going to say, "Oh,
you did it wrong." Right.
I actually think this will work. One
shot. Send it. My dude,
there is no way in hell.
I will be shocked if we have anything
that is remotely usable by the end of a
full day of doing this.
Test what you expect.
I will allow it to do stuff. Yes,
I'm going to give this like full
ability. Like we will do this in the as
correctly as possible and it's still
going to fail, man. There's no way.
How long would it take you to do this
yourself? If I'm well rested, I think I
could get a cool prototype of this in a
weekend.
Well, I mean, we'll see, right? If once
I have the full spec, if it just
one-shots it, I will be shocked beyond
belief. But like, that's basically
impossible, dude. Because if the models
were that good, the world would not look
like it wouldn't look like what it looks
like today.
Like if this were to work one shot, I
would be able to just like get myself a
couple pots of coffee and rewrite most
of modern software that I like I depend
on for AI in about a week.
There's just no way in hell.
Like if I just like if I wanted a um if
I like I would basically be able to say
okay like go port me tiny from Python to
C and would it that would just work
right cuz that's super testable every
bit of that is testable and then I'd
have a C framework and then I'd say okay
remove this this and that and like I
would no longer depend on PyTorch. We'd
have 30 million step per second RL
within a few days.
I like [laughter]
there's so much stuff that would just be
like completely different. I just do not
believe it is possible for stuff to be
that good. I've done with my physics
engine moving to CUDA. Have you seen
some of the [ __ ] I've had to do for 40
though, man?
Have you seen some of it?
PyTorch is harder. It's out of
distribute. How the heck could it
possibly be out of distribution? There's
more AI on the internet than anything
else. There's so much PyTorch example
code.
Why are my long comments skipped?
Because I'm using reream and if you type
too much stuff, sometimes it skips
stuff.
Basically something a junior engineer
that is diligent could do is somewhat it
can do it.
I hope you're wrong in the answer that
no one has the queue. I look, dude, if
that's the case, yay. Lucky me. I get to
go. I could I could if that were the
case, I could literally do two hours of
work per day and just go do whatever the
hell else and stuff would just work. But
I don't think that's the case. I
honestly think that this is just people
wanting stuff to be easy and it's not.
Stuff is hard.
models can do what they can't. All
right.
All right. What What do we have in this
spec versus what are we missing?
Oh, but you didn't do it right. So, this
is why I'm streaming at SRZ. So, I don't
know how many people we have watching on
X because there is not an indicator. But
on YouTube and Twitch right now, we have
we have almost 80 people watching. So,
if I'm doing it wrong, that's on you
guys, not me. because all of you can
tell me what I'm doing wrong.
I don't give a [ __ ] who I'm smarter
than, man. I get stuff done that works.
Like I built Puffer
and I continue to build Puffer Loop.
one of them.
See, I think what's happening there
though, man, is like you're doing work
in an area that you don't have deep
familiarity with. So, it feels like
magic,
but it's because you don't have deep
familiarity in those areas.
fixing the flow. Yeah. Okay. We have
everybody fixing stuff
wouldn't exist not for buffer. Hey, and
you let me know when you want to chat
about stuff, man, as well.
Um,
okay.
Well, guys, you're saying let it rip.
This is not a full spec, is it? I mean,
if you guys think this is a full spec,
we can send this, but I don't think
there's like not enough information here
for me to implement the environment,
right? Like the only reason I could
implement the environment from this is
because I've played the fight 700 times.
I mean, I have given it the wiki page.
Let's go through this.
What are the two obvious mis the
mistakes a junior can make?
The ones that are unreoverable are just
making a mess of the code.
It's a full spec. Let it rip.
[sighs]
It will Google search and get
if you gave me I could do it just okay
fine fine let I will give people let it
rip. It will take time. Fine. Okay,
fine. We will. Is there anything that I
need to add that's like obvious?
Cuz I think this is like a half of a
spec. But if you guys think that this is
reasonable, then sure.
If you gave this to me, I could do Okay,
fine.
Well, I mean, you guys are like, we
didn't even tell it where
there. Let me at least add that.
Give it a link to the docs. I did.
There's docs. There's wiki page.
So plan mode is on. What should I just
tell this like go read spec.ext and
start implementing the project described
there.
Turn this off.
Okay.
And turn on thinking mode. Thinking mode
is true.
Is this it?
Shift tab and ask it to plan. This is
plan mode is on.
So instead of begin implementing, it's
begin planning.
Is this what we want? Is this is this
what you guys think is the correct usage
of these models?
Go
tell it to make a plan to review and ask
questions.
edit
and edit
this something like this. No questions.
Just send it.
slashclear reset context.
Uh, there shouldn't really be anything
in the context. I haven't been you I
haven't done anything with the context
yet.
You're way overthinking it. You said
just Okay.
What?
I think that this is nuts that everybody
here is like telling me that this is
going to work. Yeah, we did it.
There's no like I will be shocked if
this gives me like anything remotely
close to working at all.
See you in 20 minutes.
It already didn't hit.
Canton won't play these M's. But is this
true? Playing Pokemon. So stalker. So
how much money they spend on Pokemon?
Yeah, that one's really funny.
powered by Puffer Lib.
Full game done with a 10 million
parameter policy.
And this is also like the worst possible
case for us because Pokemon Red is about
a thousand times slower than the
environments that we built. So, it's
like very heavily data constrained.
I'm honestly shocked that we did so well
and they did so poorly on this one.
Like,
but there you go.
No bugs, please.
It will be set up but have some sort of
bugs that make it nonfunctable.
Nonfunctional. I don't think it'll even
get that, man. I don't think it'll be
remotely close.
It isn't to train a 1000x 10 mil.
Well, but the thing is you assume that
you need bigger models to solve hard
problems and you don't. You have in your
head the size of models for language,
but like you can absolutely train models
with less than 10 million parameters to
do useful tasks.
The thing is we scale way more data.
How many players
We'll do configurable
movement attack and prayer
attack style prayer toggle. That seems
good.
Do I want I can't do four directional
movement.
Um, so it's going to have to be
movement is what? It's eight
nine.
Player death only
death or player death.
This is fine.
What reward structure?
Well, you can't obviously reward for
kill. It'll have to be
How's that 25 directional? It's a 5x5,
right?
Or am I stupid? No, I'm not stupid.
Right. Two on each side is a 5x5 grid,
right?
It cannot interface with the end if it
has a renderable interface. Yeah, it'll
be able. But the thing is with this, we
can have it just implement a um a super
simple grid renderer as well as some
tests. Man,
plus it can also ask me to test it. Is
this your first time? Yes. The only
reason I'm doing this is because people
would not stop bothering me to do it.
And as you see, lo and behold, we now
have like 80 people watching this plus
however many are on X. Um,
I think this is a mix of people who like
are expecting this to fail and be very
funny and a and people who think that
this is really going to actually work.
Five times five with you in the center
of the grid. Yeah, that's how it works,
right? Because you can sprint. So you
can you can move two tiles in any
direction or one tile or you cannot
move.
I even have it installed on my phone
right now or I'd show you.
Wouldn't be particularly surprised by
either outcome. I'll be shocked if this
works.
like
you know, this is a fairly short
project,
but it's not trivial, right? Like this
is not something I could go implement in
two hours.
Like the thing is most of the things
that I could do start to finish in two
hours are by definition like
there's not that much like there's
really not that much that the models can
help me with. Um because like most of
the tasks that I do are not things that
I just start and finish in two hours,
right?
Like most of my work is on the core of
puffer and that's way harder. So I had
to at least give it a medium complexity
environment.
YouTube vid on the fight. Yeah, I got
you. Let me go get uh Hang on. I have
I've got a tab that doesn't have um
I probably, if I looked, I'd probably
have streamed that fight. I used to
stream old school a little bit.
Uh,
I'm trying to think if anybody just has
gameplay that's not a guide.
Yeah, these are all like super stylized
and they show everything, but they like
nobody just has the gameplay.
Oh, here I found somebody just soloing
it with no commentary.
Oops. Hang on. Let me I'll bring this
over in one second, guys.
Well, uh, cloud code is still going. No,
wait. Okay.
if it works.
If it even remotely impresses you,
good luck with that, man.
If it gets 85%, I will be shocked. I
don't even think it's going to do 15,
man.
Stay the world. Make different way to
play it for functional tests. Yeah, we
can do that. That's fine.
Yeah. So this is the fight. So this is
the thing. This is why I think it's so
cool of a fight because you see how this
person is not getting hit. This is a
perfect cycle in which if you move
exactly in this way, the head doesn't
see you when you're over here and then
it goes to turn to you, but you're
already moving. So it's like really cool
cuz it's this simple fight that uh can
be complete chaos, but if you actually
know what you're doing, you can do it
completely perfectly and you get this
really cool looking cycle. Uh, and I
think it would be really awesome to see
if RL agents discover this, provided the
sim supports it. And if we make the sim
playable, I know how to do this, so I
can actually test it. Um, this is
probably the single piece of content in
all of gaming that I've spent the most
time on. I really love the design of
this and like the old school MMO rating
type thing. There's just so much
interesting stuff in there both from
this perspective of like game design but
also of uh test beds for AI and like a
lot of the mechanics and things from
this directly inspired uh work
throughout my PhD
in multiplayer. What happens when a
single player dies?
Episode continues. Uh player responds.
So yeah, we do player responds.
Players have an attack cool down. Uh
four tick is yes, you have a four tick
cool down. Everything is four tick
weapon. That's fine.
Okay.
There's tick man. This is not tick
manipulation.
Yeah, we're good, man.
Something I learned about RL are all RL
papers are complete and total [ __ ]
Yep. Group of things they done really
because just one banded they added a
Yeah, most of the papers are like that.
Not all of them. There are a few good
papers, but very few, man.
Yeah, I'm going to let it just edit
plan.ext whenever it wants because it's
it own internal doc.
Yeah. So what this person is doing here
is actually much more complicated. Um
that is a method that reduces the number
of hits you take.
You can see the pathing is quite
complex.
There are a few other things going on
there as well where I I don't it doesn't
even need to get that level of
sophistication for me to be happy. If we
can get something that remotely looks
like the fight and that supports that
kind of initial loop, I will be happy. I
just doubt that it happens. Okay. Uh
let's see. Files to modify.
Okay. It's allowed to do this. Fine.
Yes. And
if I say auto accepted, it's only going
to be able to edit these files, right?
Actually, I will defer to you guys. Do
you manually approve each thing here or
do you auto accept?
Manual always auto accept everything
manual.
I will give it the ability to run the
code. It's better if I do it manually,
right? You're saying like it's so good
that it'll work even if we do auto,
right?
No auto accept. Just Okay, fine.
If it doesn't work, we'll go back and do
it again.
Clear the Why would I clear the context,
dude? It should be super super short
context.
What are you just trying to save token
charges?
So yeah, that's the fight. Um,
you can see here as well. Watch this. So
he kills that hand.
Come on.
And now he's going to hit the melee hand
immediately
because you have to defeat the hands of
the What is he doing?
What
did they change the fight?
You have to defeat the hands at the same
time or it resets.
Huh?
You have something's weird with that.
Usually, when I remember, you'd have to
defeat both of them at the same time or
they would reset.
I think it's going to do well on this on
this. So, this is why I picked it, man.
This should be the best possible case.
And I just there's no way. There is no
way. Uh as for good papers,
uh yeah, PO has stood the test of time.
Uh mostly it's like there are some norm
things that you need to do, but like
that has stood the test of time. Uh the
Dota paper is amazing. Like that's
probably been the paper I got the most
stuff from. That team was amazingly
amazingly talented. Uh as well,
there's some stuff from Go Explore that
I plan on using relatively soon. Um,
what other papers are there? Sample
factory actually I don't like everything
that they did, but they got a lot of
pretty solid infrastructure in there.
Does clean have a paper? I don't know if
they actually have a paper. Clean RL is
of course awesome. Open AI papers on RL.
Um, well, not all of them.
Not all of them. Can you explain what
this game is about? Uh, so this is
Runescape. It is one of the biggest
MMOs. Obviously, I'm not trying to
implement the whole thing. I'm just
trying to implement this one fight that
is on the screen.
And not even the full thing, like not
even the gear switching, like not even a
full simulator of it, right?
But if I can just get this basic cycle
that he's doing here, like this mechanic
of move and hit like this, if I can get
this behavior, I'd be very happy
already.
ELO when I run a tournament is not
scaling with training over time. Very
wait. ELO when I run a run tournament is
not scaling. What's that? Target 3D or
2D? The dynamics are the same either
way. The rendering can be whatever we
want.
Uh, it did figure out that it had to add
this. That's pretty nice.
See, it's uh it is able to build the
code. Look, Destiny, I gave it access.
It can build the code right here.
Need could be re uh need's a little
sketchy. Like that's really small
models, man.
I don't know why it's building with no
train.
Okay, fine.
Wait,
let me build the Python bindings.
So, I mean, yeah, you can see that's the
full uh the full thing is a lot more
complex. Like, if I were to implement
the full full fight, that would be quite
a bit more.
That would probably be a few thousand
lines.
The heck is it saying that it's not
building
Oh,
I see.
Yeah, I had to set this thing up locally
because I didn't want to have rendering
bugs like with remote rendering. Okay.
spending turning across checkpoints to
calculate real elo and then matching up
against selfplay.
Do you have versus stockfish?
That should give you a really high
confidence evaluation.
All right, so yeah, this is the whole
fight that I've left up. I actually I
forgot that you can pretty much avoid
I don't know if it's every hit. Oh, it
is every hit, isn't it? Yeah. So, you
literally don't even get hit on the uh
the last phase if you do it this way.
Though, sometimes these things can get
in the way,
but it's mechanically it's a very
interesting setup and I think that RL
would just crush this completely.
Um, and it would produce some really
interesting learning curves and
strategies,
but
I don't know. Several people seem to
think that this like that you'll just be
able to do this out of the box with
Claude or pretty close. I will be
shocked.
Yeah, RL will crush this. It's actually
Yeah. seen. It's kind of funny to me
because the thing I really like about
MMOs, they're all these really difficult
mechanical tasks that RL just crushes
and then there are a bunch of things
that are really easy for us where RL is
not going to work. And it it's a very
good problem to think about uh RL in
I'm shocked by RL and much more. So if
we have it up to 7 million steps per
second training with a brand new
architecture in Puffer 4 and we're going
to get up to uh 10 million before
release. So imagine that. Imagine
sweeping at 10 million steps per second.
That's going to happen.
100k triangles, 16k world with 2 mil on
GPU.
I'm trying to think if that's fast.
Yeah, the rendering is probably a pain
for that, right?
Yeah, the rendering is a pain for that
sim to real with no measurements come
outside of the body of the agent.
Yeah, this stuff is gonna there is so
yeah there there are actually a few core
like real algorithmic improvements that
RL still needs that are not [ __ ] and
will not just be papers that don't work.
Uh I have those in the works. It's going
to just take some time.
Okay, the great boss fight RL
environment is now implemented and
tested. So, it thinks it has it thinks
it has an environment.
It has something that actually builds.
Hang on.
So, should I edit this manually
or
uh or should I tell it to make all
edits?
Anyways, well, I have no idea if this is
remotely anything, right?
Oh yeah, this is going to be a mess.
It doesn't understand the frame rate
thing.
What?
Wait. I'm trying to figure out what it
thinks what it thinks is happening.
Wait, what is
what is supposed to even be what?
Like they're going up here. So, where's
the boss?
What game is this? This is the test that
we have for um for Opus.
It's Hang on.
Well, okay. Whatever. It's this fight
for Runescape.
QA with a spec.
Uh, that we wrote a spec for this.
Elliot,
is that how it's supposed to look? I
mean, I don't really care how they it
looks if it's actually like reasonably
correct, but I don't think it is. Like,
I'm trying to figure out what it did.
So, this is
Wait. Right claw.
So I'm supposed to just be able to ask
it, right?
Melee. Wait. Players attacked there.
Yellow triangle is M's facing direction.
Colored circles.
Oh, okay. Okay. So, the boss I don't
think is drawn on screen
I'm I'm unsure of what I'm looking at.
TBH, though am I.
So, am I impressed or what? Why are you
guys asking me if I'm impressed when I
have no idea whether this is remotely
correct or usable yet?
Poke around. Red puffers. Nice. So,
yeah, the problem is it'll get a little
faster with Puffer 4, but the the
problem with Pokemon is that that
environment itself is the slow bit.
This gets done with or without AI.
Yeah, I mean, I definitely this is an
environment. I was thinking of doing
something like this manually at some
point as well.
And we'll see how uh we'll see how the
AI does.
And this is where it does see. So it's
just a test script
breakout plus Atari instead of puffer
breakout. That actually is a pretty good
idea. Um,
Yeah,
I don't mind this as much cuz this is
just the test script. But I bet you the
chords is every bit as bad.
play market and cle and yeah, we'll see.
Why nests? Yeah, I know. I know. It's
whatever. Hang on.
This is actually one of the things I
train new devs to not do.
It actually this condition is pretty
much completely redundant as well.
If it were to just put this above
manage context.
So just slash contact. Whoops.
Okay, this is the here's going to be the
question for folks, right? I got to use
the restroom real quick and grab myself
a drink. But the question for folks next
is
I can't exactly tell if whe whether this
is working correctly or not because the
rendering is too low fidelity. I also
don't want to make it like try to do
some super fancy rendering and screw up.
So, I'm thinking if we add just basic uh
basic projectiles,
like basic basic projectiles, so we can
see what see when stuff is landing and
like basic hit splats.
Then we'll be able to see whether this
is even remotely close.
Uh the other thing we could do is start
looking at the code manually and see if
like and try to understand what the hell
it did
such that you could play it. Okay, I
think that is the best idea. We'll make
it We'll try to get it to the rendering
is good enough so that I can play it and
then I can see if it feels good. Yeah,
give me like one minute, folks. Oh, and
we have at least 100 people watching,
not including um not including Twitter
right now. So, uh for everybody
watching, if you'd like to support my
work for absolutely free, please just
start the repo. Like I do all of my
actual RL dev on the environments and on
the new algorithms that we do and on
hyperf kernels like manually by hand.
This is kind of a one-off thing. Uh just
start the puffer. It helps a lot. It's
all open source. I work on it more than
full-time. I'll be right back and then
we'll see if we can actually make this
playable.
Second thing here. Whoops. One moment,
folks.
This is so funny.
I think I'm here with my family and I
think they like put the stream on
downstairs or something cuz they heard
me ranting and brought me tea. So, yay.
Thanks, Ma.
Okay.
Um
yeah. So second thing here we need this
lurp. Um basic projectile
basic
attack animations
What trade tea? Just like English
breakfast tea. A crash out of people say
the reason why this fails is because you
didn't compress context often enough.
But we really should clear the context.
Just reference what we've built as a way
to compress
puffer lib type policies running on a
microcontroller.
We actually have, wait, yeah, we
literally have a library that does that
for you, right? Like we have the the C
library.
Don't clear context. Cool. Just tapped
in water updates. It made something
runnable that I have no idea whether or
not is correct. And that's what we're
trying to figure out at the moment.
I'm honestly most impressed by I didn't
even know that you could do this on a
standard term.
Clear context folks are trolling.
All right,
someone switch back into plan mode for
every query.
If if I'm doing something wrong, let me
know. That is the point. We have enough
people watching that I want there to be
like no possible, oh, you did it wrong.
I hear you changing your mind. You don't
hear any such thing yet. I don't know if
any of this is remotely correct.
Like, it makes sense that it's going to
produce something that looks reasonable.
Now whether it is actually reasonable is
yet to be determined.
Feel like an exponential improvement
over the last model you tried. I don't
know until I actually go look at the
like the I have it's going to take a
while into the day before I have any
real assessment. Right. For now, we're
just seeing how far we can get building
this
true bottleneck on software, which is
how long it takes things to compile
instantaneous. Write some C or how long
it takes to train a model. Instantaneous
trip for lip.
Model will ask you questions to clarify.
So, did it just take plan mode off like
automatically and I should just do that
again?
mode wasn't. Okay. So, I'll put it back
on then once uh we'll do this one and
then I'll put it back on the next thing.
WS
Let's say
Now it's looking at me.
Okay.
and the player's not wait there. No
projectiles from the player as well.
Interesting. Um,
move up.
Okay. So, I can't see I can't see my
overheads and I can't see the tile the
style I'm getting hit with.
Visual testing is hard. You have to do
it manually and inform it which is not a
good idea. This is exactly a good idea.
This is exactly how you test like game
environments. In fact, the whole point
of using games as environments is that
you can test them like this and you get
very good feedback, right? Was
it shift tab? Okay, there's plan mode.
Um, well, we don't need this though for
this is a very small change, I think.
So, this is just going to be
fix projectile
colors.
It will easier if it can do the visual
testing itself.
Yeah, but how the hell is it supposed to
do that?
It's very very difficult to develop a
game without um without having visual
feedback.
Like I could technically have it try to
do an asy renderer or something, but
like
that's just going to chew up a bunch of
context and it like not going to be the
easiest thing for it to interpret.
Hello, welcome. This is the stream. This
is the stream that I promised where I'm
trying Opus. Um, and we're seeing if
it's actually any good.
Okay, so it had a couple of the colors
swapped. That was confusing.
And then it adds some rectangles. Cool.
Screenshot images. I will do that next
time. And then for the uh the next thing
we want to add
Is the Wait, are the keys not
responsive? Is that what's going on?
Hang on. I think it did the key presses
wrong.
Yeah.
Let me see if it's the movement keys or
not. It's very It's like very awkward.
It's The keys are not doing what I
expect them to do.
That looks slopp
This is my expectation. Um, now to be
fair, this is supposed to be a lowfi
renderer. Uh, the question is whether
it's correct or not.
How do you run the environment on
websites? Can't you make it do that
instead? Yeah, I can. We'll be able to
compile the exact same code for web.
It's C. You compile the web assembly.
Okay. Yeah, something is wrong with the
um here.
Should I do splash compact or right
after this? I suppose. Yeah, after this.
If you consider this done task, it's not
remotely done, dude.
If it were able to interact with the end
of itself, it can't though. And that's
fun. Like is
it can't and that's the problem, right?
Key mapping.
Actions. It should have been able to
figure out though because it could do
that through tests.
This one should be quite easy though.
Okay. See this?
Hopefully this is at least still
runnable.
I mean that's a very basic common bug.
So that's fine. That's fixed enough.
webdev. You can give it playright MC
test the app
It's able to run it's able to run the um
to build this and run it though like it
can run tests on this
Okay. So, let's see.
What the heck is this?
It's got the mage uh the prayer sim
thing. Reasonableish.
Okay. So, it's actually like kind of
there.
First of all, I want to see what the
hell the code looks like a little bit.
I did estimate a thousand lines and it's
just under a thousand lines now.
Um,
okay. It did actually copy the strct
format. Good.
uh to be determined. Jess, the thing is
I don't want to say, "Oh, yeah, this is
super impressive." Because the thing is
like
it's definitely always going to be
superficially impressive and the real
test is going to be like when I have to
go into like can I actually finish this
thing or is it going to just be a
complete and utter mess when you really
start digging into it, right?
How much faster did this do the work?
Well, like it's not done yet is the
thing, right?
like getting a basic thing for this
would probably be a weekend project for
me.
It only saves work time, right? If when
I like when I actually go to make it
properly work, if it doesn't take me
longer to fix it than it would have
taken me to just write the thing, right?
don't need like five hours to debug.
It's not just debugging though because
it's like this is one part of it.
There's also the whole RL side of it
that I have to do.
I will say that the one thing that seems
to have gotten quite a bit better is
this is a lot closer to how I would
implement this than uh the previous
models. But like this is also again the
best possible case because this has
thousands and thousands of lines of my
code for similar projects to this to ref
to refer to.
Implementing it yourself is much more
fun than fixing. Yeah. So that's the
problem. If I end up having to spend
five hours fixing horrible bugs versus
five hours like, you know, actually
working on a cool new project, um, one
of those two things is going to burn me
out way more and just suck a lot more
than the other, right?
Which is why I say it's like way too
early to assess.
roughly implemented how I'd expect.
Okay. Um,
but I think it's not monitoring
everything quite.
I the thing now I need to I guess I need
to know the exact mechanics now so that
I can figure out how to have this thing
uh fully implemented correctly.
Now, I'm forgetting a couple details
with the fight. Like, I'm forgetting
when damage is calculated.
I think damage is calculated when the
projectile is fired.
We need to get the full map.
Has it done done better than you
expected? Looks like it's done more than
15%.
Uh, it probably has, but the thing is
there are multiple ways to add up to
15%. Right? So if it does 50% of the
work but then also introduces like 50%
of the engineering time worth of bugs
and things that I have to fix manually,
right? So it's like it's actually going
to be tough to say until it gets a
little farther. When it gets to the
point that it's actually like playable
and is roughly matching and I look at
the code and it's reasonable, I'd be a
lot more confident. But like I want to
see how that loop goes with it.
There's this thing.
Okay, here we can see it. Can we count
though?
Oh, yeah. Yeah, this is a good image. I
can count based on this, right?
Ah. Ads. Garbage ads.
Open. Where's the image? Open image in
new tab. There. Okay,
ask it lots of questions about the code.
Yeah, I I can definitely I actually
think that based on what I see, I can
probably get it to refactor things
cleanly. The question is just going to
be if it falls apart as like it tries to
get closer to the real thing.
Yeah, Pino this is again this is the the
point of the stream is we're evaluating
this evaluating not evaluated
right
will be farmed for useful mechanics
uh well my guy have you seen like
right there you go there is Uh,
what?
Yo, Google, why? Where's my thesis?
Oh, there it is. Yeah, there's 170 page
thesis
directly from uh I I took so many
mechanics directly from the game, man.
Other MMOs as well, other games too, but
like, you know.
Okay. One, two, three,
four, five, six,
seven. Wait.
Five. Six. Seven.
Eight. Nine.
19. I think it's only really 19 tiles.
It's actually so it's 19 tiles across
map 19 tiles across
head turn
zone [snorts] three tiles
side five
See, one, two, three, four, five, six,
just make them out. You can make them at
10.
Love you most. Well, you don't
necessarily need to read my whole
thesis, man. Uh the my thesis defense is
on YouTube. So, if you want like a
polished one-hour piece of content,
you can go start with that. And then
there's a whole bunch of material on my
latest work, which is far far far more
stuff. Uh, we literally have neural MMO
on puffer.ai. You can play it and you
can watch our agents play it.
secret. This is the initial test, right?
This is like the initial test.
What's your time limit today?
I'm spending today on this and we'll see
how it goes.
What is it doing?
Oh, okay. That's fine.
Not afraid of rate limits.
Let me go check.
my account.
Oops. Close that.
What is the task you're currently
spending today on? So Paul, the idea of
this stream here is everybody's been
bugging me like, "Oh, the latest models
are so good. The latest models are go so
good." So I said, "Fine, I'll do a
stream. I'll come up with the task that
I think is like best suited possibly for
these language models and see if they
remotely work. Um, and this is at the
moment we are implementing the great M
fight from Old School Runescape. Uh,
we're not doing all the specials or
anything yet, but we're trying to get
like the basic fight implemented as a
high performance reinforcement learning
sim.
This is freaking expensive.
Um,
no it isn't. That's actually the one
thing you won't hear me complain about
because if this is like at all useful to
me, my time is worth dramatically more
than $11. So,
if it's useful is the keyword. Exactly.
It has to actually be useful.
I'd also like to say I I don't think
I've done a single thing that remotely
resembles thinking today at all.
So, at the very least, for the people
who say there's some skill to it or
actually like, you know, it's actually
harder or this or that, that's just
horseshit.
So, that chunk for sure
is uh nuts.
big flex in this economy. What economy?
The economy is totally fine.
Who is claiming it's harder?
I've seen literally like many people
including people at the uh at the big
lab say this
need a bit of thinking on building the
scaffold that the AI uses to work. Yeah,
but that's like nothing compared to
actually writing the code.
Like the people who say programming was
never the hard part obviously never did
any real programming.
miles don't work. You're bad at system
design.
He was in here before. I don't know if
he's still here.
He said that this would oneshot the
environment, by the way,
Can't do any low-level or
performance-based programming.
You like you're just doing logic the
entire time. So, frankly, the hardest
part of programming for me is just like
maintaining the level of energy and
focus I need to be thinking about the
whole thing and not making a mess the
whole time when like you know you're
thinking at things you're thinking about
a lot more things than you are thinking
about when you're just calling some dumb
highle API with no notion whatsoever of
things taking time on the CPU.
Right?
Very highly skilled programmer.
Carmarmac.
That'll be CarMax.
Not really. I can describe it though
into the spec sheet. This would be going
better. T I was going to put more effort
into the spec sheet and the entire chat
told me, "No, no, this is good enough.
Start going." So, I'm not going to take
that answer one bit.
Is this prompting reading loop fun?
Um,
uh, no. It's not particularly fun, but
it I like it's also not hard in the
least. Like, this is using this requires
zero brain cells.
Drag in screenshots. All right, let me
do that.
The models are going to make us dumb.
Exactly. This is like
I mean there's really nothing going on
here that resembles thinking.
One, two, three.
I think it's five tiles.
Yeah. Debugging code you haven't written
is absolutely exhausting.
Use cloud code his first time. Learn for
Exactly.
Using these tools while maintaining
mental effort.
Like Luke, I honestly there are chunks
of things that if the models are
actually good.
Like the other possibility, right, is
let's say that I actually think that
these models are good at some stuff.
Another entirely different like another
possibility I could see is that I like
them, but I hate the way that they're
being used, right?
Like this loop of don't read the code
feels particularly [ __ ] to me.
Let me finish I like let me do the full
stream before and think about it for a
bit first. Man,
I'm going to have to do a whole blog
post on this.
More meetings than ever before. Yeah. So
I mean the thing is you should just not
be in meetings.
note that there will be no excuse of
like oh you used the like you used it
wrong. I literally have I still have 90
plus people uh watching this who can be
telling me if I'm doing anything wrong
and that is the point of this dream. So,
this is meant to be a good thorough
evaluation.
It's got to include finishing a full
prototype of the environment, uh, being
able to play it, probably training a
basic agent on it to do something at
least
and evaluating the code that it wrote.
5K on X. Yeah, but it's not 5K
concurrent. X doesn't actually tell you
the concurrent view count. So I have no
idea how many are concurrent on X.
You think we know what we're doing? Uh
it's not that I necessarily think you
know what you're doing. Uh there are a
lot of people who seem to think that
there's a lot that you need to know in
order to be doing stuff with the LLMs.
So those people who think that there's a
skill to it or that there's like
substantial room to do it wrong, like go
ahead. You have your opportunity, right?
How much money have you spent on tokens?
Let me double check.
How much?
Uh, that
like 16 bucks.
Skilled to have a depression.
That one is just particularly funny to
me. like they think that there's skill
gap with um it the funniest thing to me
is the people who have not actually ever
gotten good at programming thinking that
there's a skill gap to using the tools.
I will like I'll accept that there might
be a few like unintuitive things but
there's really no
like there's no real difference between
oh you have to prompt it versus you have
to write a spec and writing a spec is
dramatically easier than writing the
code in the first place. So,
and nobody even writes good specs
anyways, like ever
even professionally. I deal with a lot
of them
any good single link you'd recommend.
Wait to give what a go, man.
RL or video game being Yeah, I have like
I have detailed guides on this. um like
they don't include a bunch of LLM usage,
but if you just check my X articles tab,
I have a detailed guide on programming
and science, and then I have a guide on
uh like my ultra opinionated guide on
RL. So, there's a ton of stuff.
Oh, is not the easiest thing to start
off on.
Simpler
Uh because JAD would just be trivial,
man. Like JAD would be a super trivial
thing to implement.
Like I could probably do a decent JADS
sim in a day and it would only it
wouldn't be even a reasonable amount of
code. It'd be like three 400 lines.
I mean, you can literally just kick Jad
to death as well,
you know.
Impression so far. Not going to give
until it's fully done. Um, skills or
commands or workflows, I haven't found
them. Yeah, the whole like that whole
side it seems increasingly bullshitty.
So, we will see though.
We shall see. Okay,
so this is that is a lot closer.
Uh, nice projectiles, by the way.
Why did the range projectile come out
that fast? [laughter]
That's funny. Let's see if melee works.
Yeah, melee works. And if I step away,
I'm no longer hitting it, right?
Should one start reading the R Sutton
book? Uh, if you really like math, yes.
Otherwise, you'll get bored and stop if
you do that. Just read my guide. My
guide covers everything and like my
guide is not just my material. It will
link you to other stuff.
My advice is it subscribe. No, no, no,
no. Hang on. Like let me clear this up
guys. So I don't have anything to sell
you. Okay, let's make this very clear.
My content for users is all free. My
library is free. Okay, so this is not
like guys selling you courses or
[ __ ] All right. Uh the way that I
make money is I build sims for companies
RL simulations professionally and I do
like you know enterprise stuff around
what I build. But all the core stuff
that I build it's all free. It's all
open source. We got a big open source
community. I stream all the science and
research as well. And these articles are
free. The subscriber stuff is also only
for companies. So don't worry about
that.
It's these two
here. Let me link you this.
What are some of your favorite video
games? MMOs, man.
Probably have the most number of hours
in Runescape. So, that's why I thought
it would be a good uh a good fit for
this.
My Jarus coffee mug is [laughter]
Oh, funny.
No, I have not played. I have not played
RS in like three years, I think. And I
have not played any MMO in well, not any
MMO. I haven't played my other main MMO
in like two years. I downloaded WoW for
a bit over vacation because I knew I
wouldn't get hooked on it and I didn't.
Um,
yeah, no more MMO playing until we solve
RL.
I don't have I've never played F uh I've
never played FFI Final Fantasy whatever
the hell 14 MMO
a lot of time in DOUS a lot of time in
old school
tougher merks when when the company is
big enough to merit it
and when we've actually like solved the
Do you have your setup for this? For
what? What you're seeing here?
This is just cloud code. Like the point
of this stream is that we're testing
this model. For reference, like I never
code this way ever. Like you don't see
me you don't see me vibe coding [ __ ]
ever. So everybody's been begging me to
do this stream. So like that's the idea
today.
and I will probably write a post on it
and we'll see whether like what chunks
of this influence how I do stuff in the
future, but I'm going to need some time
to think about it.
Do we know the viz actually represent
something? Yeah, there's a sim
underneath it, right?
What do you mean, do we know it
represents something?
Puffer lip is running the simulation to
write the player location and you're
using opus. No, Opus in this case, look
in this case, the point of today is that
Opus is writing this simulation
and then I'm just running the sim code,
right? So, Opus is not in the loop right
now at all. It's just writing the code
for this. It's basically implementing a
game if the game had to run 10,000 times
faster than normal and also be
structured in a way that uh is useful
for RL, right?
Is the environment working? It's closer.
Yet to be determined, though.
It's possible to solve the field. I'm a
little bit facicious with that after
story, but like realistically, I think
within the next year I can get it to the
point where medium-sized RL tasks that
would take a couple months of dedicated
work are just solved out of the box and
are able to be done so on one GPU pretty
much automatically.
Did it do OBS and stuff? Yeah. So, we're
not sure yet. We're not doing the
training yet. I We're going to make sure
we're going to do OBS and stuff after we
see that the Sim is correct.
Why does your health decrease when the
projectiles don't hit? Because the
projectile uh the projectile pathing is
wrong. Like, you can't dodge projectiles
in Runescape. Like, they should just
follow you. So it's the rendering is
wrong.
Do you use LMS at all? So when I do my
normal work, I use LLMs in two ways. I
have in editor, I have Super Maven,
which is a really stupid model. It's
like really dumb, but it's fast. It
autocompletes instantly. I use it as
essentially a fuzzy LSP.
It cannot think for you but it can fill
in like it can make you type faster
basically. And then for docs, I will use
whatever other slightly heavier model uh
that still runs reasonably fast, right?
Sonnet, Brock, whatever the hell.
I do not use LLMs to write big chunks of
code in my normal work.
Which is why this is uh you know the
special stream
cloud code able to do all this is
amazing. Like uh 24 we have to actually
get the end of end to end before we can
say that, right?
Because it could be that like it looks
great and then when I like really start
going to make the RL work, we find a
million errors.
How long will you stream today? Good
while. We've only been live three hours.
That is a very short stream so far by my
standards.
What's the speed compared to Sarah? Oh,
Cabris is like way faster. It's not even
close.
But I haven't like I still don't use
Cabris to write code though, you know.
I was using it for docs and stuff for a
while because it was fast.
People recommend allow cloud to be able
to verify its own work. Is it feasible?
Yeah, it is able to run the command like
it has the command to compile this and
to run it and it can run tests.
That's the first thing I gave it.
Llama Vim for autocomplete. Uh, no I
haven't because so far um so Cursor
technically bought Super Maven and they
were going to shut it down but then
everybody complained. So so far they
have not shut it down and I just it's
good and it's fast.
Using Clang D. I'm using what is it
using? I think it's just clang. I forget
if it's GCC or Clang. That's it. You
going to put up a post summarizing
everything? Uh, most likely yes once I
have had time to think, but I like it's
we're not done yet, right?
Like anybody who started a uh a
substantial project can tell you that
the easiest thing about like the easiest
thing is very quickly developing
something that looks almost right and
kind of cool, right? Like the question
is going to be can we actually finish
the project or do we hit a billion
issues,
right?
Daniel, the VOD will be on YouTube like
they always are.
Can you make Claude run faster? No.
You kind of just have to sit here and
wait for it, which is the other not
right thing. Model doing this blind if
you've given it. Okay, let me let me re
reiterate this for new people here. I
have given Claude the best possible
scenario to make this project work. It
has full access to the puffer lip code.
It has pointers to uh other very
similarly sized environments with code
style with a correct API usage commented
with like all the techniques that are
used to make the environments run fast.
We're using an incredibly well doumented
and popular rendering library that's
very lightweight and very very easy. Uh
there's no interaction with the rest of
puffer lib required. It's a single
standalone file. Like this is the best
possible
test case I could give to Claude, right?
So like of the non-trivial problems I
could give it, this is one where it
should have the best chance of
succeeding.
See, I have no idea why it's doing this,
but whatever.
It forgot how to compile the project.
That's kind of funny.
It's asking you for perms. No, it just
forgot. It forgot the command.
It needs to be able to watch the sim run
like a human would so it can debug
itself.
Yeah, that would be substantially harder
though, right?
like video input.
The model doesn't even support that,
right?
What the [ __ ] is Clawude doing? It just
forgot the it forgot the build command
um from the context even though I gave
it to it in the initial spec
represent the graphics. Nasty. Yeah, I
thought about that. I don't think that
that would be great for it either
though. I think it's just going to burn
a bunch of context and like not actually
fully convey what you need
for this use case. Way harder or ti.
Yeah, I think it's fine because like I
am happy testing this and telling it
what to fix if it can actually fix
stuff. Um the thing is I'm suspecting
that we're going to just run into a ton
of problems as we try to actually like
get something fully working. We will
see.
You see, I think that I I don't know if
it's perfectly correct, but this is the
type of the cycle thing that we wanted.
It's tick perfect. I think if I stole an
extra tick,
do I get hit?
Is it not tick perfect?
If I stole a tick,
I might have stole two ticks there.
Oh, but I think the head is turning too
early or something.
I'm not so confident about this.
This model had your work is cutting
edge. I don't think the model had any
trading. You can probably get it done if
you do a lot of panholding.
Well, TX, so the model has access to my
code, all of my code from all of my
environments. Um,
so this includes like many examples of
environments I've written with the exact
code style, the exact optimizations.
Right? This is a simpler environment as
well uh than the more complicated ones I
wrote. This is like a medium complexity
end,
I'd say. At least without all the
special attacks and stuff, just like the
base environment.
The problem isn't cutting edge RL. No,
this is a medium complexity environment.
And in fact, it'll be a very simple
environment as it's written, right? Like
you have to at least add a couple
specials and stuff to make it harder.
Oh, it's respawning me. Not on a Look at
this. It's respawning me not on a tile,
right?
I think the workflow alone will make you
hate this type of programming. Yeah,
probably lotto. But that doesn't mean I
can't evaluate it and like think about
some stuff. Would an average to above
average puffer be user be able to get to
this point as quickly as clawed code? If
the answer is no, isn't it already
performing well?
Uh no, Winter. So the point is uh the
the metric is can it act like can it get
to
it's basically can I implement this
environment to the same quality etc
faster than if I were to just do it
myself right or easier than I could just
do it myself or better in some way. uh
average puffer lilib user is not like
as quick. Yeah, it wouldn't be the
average user because it's right now
you're not substituting an average
user's time with mine, right? Like I'm
the one who's sitting here doing this.
There's quite a bit of stuff that needs
to change. Um,
I'll just I'll leave this right here and
I'll use the restroom and then we'll
figure out what next has to be
competitive among well winter. If if our
average users can be more productive
with it, that would be good. But my
expectation, right, is that is that if
somebody who's not familiar with Puffer
just does this, like they're not like
they will just end up submitting me a
bunch of crap to review that doesn't
make sense. We will see. Why using Opus?
Because everybody asked me to for like a
month.
Yeah, exactly. This is an evaluation
stream. Any recommendations for
environments suitable for testing RL
algorithms? The simplest possible one is
our implementation of Breakout. Um,
harder than that would be, well, we have
like a set of them, right? Pong is way
too easy. Breakout's the simplest
possible one. Tetris is like a decent
medium complexity one. Uh, 2048 is like
medium high complexity. And Dural MMO is
very hard.
code using puffer right now at all or
just some graphics li um well it's it's
using the puffer lib spec right so this
is the idea is this will hook into
puffer for training it's like our end
format and the way that we write our
ends right so the idea is it's
standalone as possible but we'll also
just be able to like compile this for
our training library as well.
And that is part of the test stream for
reference.
Claire obscure expedition 33.
I don't know what that is.
Is that a game that I should know?
How is it possible to write an M that
doesn't have enough data like sports
leagues?
The point is that the sim should be the
data
verdict. So far it's doing some stuff,
but we're going to like I mean it's
really a matter of can we get it to be
like can we get a full end out of this
or am I going to end up having to do a
ton of manual stuff towards the
Yeah, it's calcing wrong. Like you see,
look at that. It's calcing the damage
when the projectile fires instead of
when it hits.
Okay. Um,
next stuff.
Six.
You told him to do that. What?
You told him to do what?
No, I said it registers. It registers
the damage. It doesn't apply the damage.
There's a difference.
Did Claude get you? No, Burns. This is a
stream like to test stuff.
one, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
I really actually need to figure out
precisely
the um the tile ranges cuz like I can't
tell if it's right until I know the uh
the tile ranges, right?
We're going to see how I like ultimately
the question is how much effort does it
take to get this prototype thingy to
something real? Um, let me make sure I
don't screw up though by not having a
sufficient
coverage of the thing.
I'm trying to remember exactly how the
fight works. I think it was
You have to run here to get it to turn.
There's another mechanic where it can
sometimes turn from here, I think.
Oh god, I'm trying to remember the exact
mechanic because the exact mechanic is
actually kind of is kind of weird. And
I'm trying to think if I need to like do
the whole thing perfectly or if I like
if I just need to get the core of it.
I think I really need like I really need
to get the full thing for this. I would
say.
training on OSRS. We're trying we're
trying to implement the great home
fight. Um
I'm trying to think if there's a uh if
there is a full
Yeah, the wiki doesn't have the uh the
exact turning mechanic.
That's a little annoying.
But I think for now we can get like I
think the mechanic for now will be
sufficient.
Um provided hang on provided.
Can you do this damageless?
Who are you and what did you do with
Joseph? Everybody's been asking me to do
a stream on this, so I'm doing a stream
on it, Lance.
Okay, so this is the the main cycle that
I wanted to implement from the real
environment. It's like if you do this,
you never get hit basically.
It's supposed to be tick perfect. I
think there's one tick of leniency in
here.
Yeah. So, here, if I do this, I can
melee and I can never get hit, right?
Okay. So this means that I should be
able to defeat you should actually be
able to defeat the boss with the current
conditions, right?
So I think we can actually try to maybe
get some basic RL on this
cuz it should be quite easy. It just
needs like a very small amount of
cleanup.
Do I enjoy using opus? No, I don't enjoy
it at all as the thing. This is like
completely brain dead work.
I mean, in the sense like I'm enjoying
the fact that I'm not thinking, but
that's bad, right?
Like this is not tiring.
It's like in the sense like you enjoy
sitting in your chair instead of going
for a run,
right?
doing other programming at the same time
or even running
in what way? Yeah. In what way? Like
in what way does this allow you to
as somebody who is intelligent and has
spent time like learning stuff? In what
way does this allow you to do more work
though
or like to build more interesting
things?
I mean, this basically feels like I have
very little control over anything. And,
you know, it's just increasingly going
to write a bunch of code that I'm going
to have to go through. Like, it this
basically feels like you're just capped
to the you're just capped to however
good the model is.
Let me actually go get a machine that
can train this.
examples where we didn't code examples.
Yeah,
I don't know. I don't think I don't
think it is a good future in which we
outsource our thinking, man.
So, like at the very least so far, I can
tell you that like it's possible that
I'm going to ultimately be impressed by
the quality of the model, but I'm going
to be I think entirely disgusted by the
implementation of this um
and like how we've chosen to use this to
replace rather than augment human
intelligence.
increased levels of abstraction. I'd say
the exact opposite. I'd say that the
increased levels of abstraction keep a
lot of people very comfortable while the
people who actually do the hard work of
understanding the lower level of things
are the ones who are actually
responsible for progress.
sweep
that requires a tremendous amount of
understanding, dude.
Like I look for all sorts of stuff and I
don't babysit said the sweep either.
It's more the analysis of it as long as
it doesn't crash.
I mean, cron will tell you if it
crashes. Like,
well, this is weird.
I messed this up.
Well, we said I'm not allowed to touch
the code. So, I'll let this make a
config as well.
through the graph breaks. I had to write
a wall clock profiler.
It's a little bit annoying though
because like
it really does seem to me like
I think it is possible that there's an
outcome in which I end up using these
tools, but I end up using them in a very
different way. Um,
I don't like just giving this control
over writing the code.
We will see though.
Also, this is the uh this is the best
possible case as well, right? like
does this work in my main code? Probably
not.
This is still an impressive application
regardless.
Um,
but I don't know. I'm going to have to
think about some stuff, man.
I review all the code and it writes
trash. So, junior engineers
and I still leverage them.
Uh, I mean, the ones that I've dealt
with with puff are like very quickly
learn
because if they don't, they don't stick
around.
What are juniors going to do? Well, I'll
tell you what they're sure as hell not
going to do, which is like type [ __ ]
into clawed code and have any value
doing that.
means they can avoid understanding.
That's not the problem, man. The problem
is that they are literally set up to do
that. That is the the way that they are
set up is to minimize understanding.
Like that's not a usage problem. That's
using them as they're designed.
I don't think I've had a single
intelligent thought all morning.
What is the desk chair? It's a It's like
a recliner. I use them instead of office
chairs. Way better.
Yeah, but the thing is like if there's
literally zero intelligent thought going
into this, then like
you're very much capped in what you can
do, right?
like I can build really awesome stuff um
when I'm thinking about things actively
at the level that I do in puffer
like implement the function that does so
and oh you so that the thing is the
level of understanding is the level of
writing the function yourself. That's
the problem.
Yeah, Anthony, it is it is actually
brain dead. That's the problem.
like this feels very self-destructive in
a way. Um because if your model is like,
oh, humans aren't going to have to think
um because the language models are going
to do this, then well, we kind of don't
need to do anything else either. Like,
may as well not exist.
Now, that's not how I like to think
about things. I'd way rather we have
these things help us understand more and
do more and learn more. But that's not
how they're set up. And I'll have to
think more about this. Let's get this
environment done though instead of
yapping about it.
Yeah, but dude, you can't be you can't
possibly tell me you're deeply thinking
about hard problems while you're also
shopping at Costco. Like, deep work
requires focus.
You still have to write the prompt.
That's brain dead.
It's act like that's completely branded.
set up in a way that's more beneficial.
So, the default architecture of it is
very heavily set up to be not that.
Yo, what the
Yo, what are we what are we installing,
dude?
Yes.
Yes, Anton.
You can focus while you let it work on
the chores.
Well, it's the opposite though at the
moment. It gives you the chores.
Yeah.
Run the background and testing your code
while you write. See, that's a lot
closer to what I would like
if I could be writing code and have it
be like, you know, taking snapshots and
checking stuff and like looking up niche
things and predicting errors before I
get them. Like things like that would be
awesome, but that's not how it's done.
Like that's not how it's set up at all.
And you can see based on how this is
like that that's not remotely how this
is set up to be used, right?
Hopefully this doesn't break it. We'll
see.
We'll lie to you constantly. Yeah,
you can't change it to be like that,
muffin. That's like rebuilding flawed
code.
That's not like a small setting like a
small tool usage change like in a way
that you're using the tool
buffer have a C API. Yeah, the
environments are a C API which is really
it's just a spec which is like if you
write your environment with these
functions and these signatures, right,
it'll be compatible.
Okay, this runs.
There's training at 4 whatever million
steps per second.
No logs though.
We give it more chance. I am giving it
more of a chance, man. We're going to
get this environment to run and train.
Okay, so this is
Hang on one second, folks.
seems to be sucking the fun out of
programming. Yeah, absolutely.
Is the n No, it's not. That's 9 million
eval, dude. 9 million eval.
What? Let me see what this is. It's like
4 point something mil right now. This is
puffer three, by the way. This is not
even puffer 4. Um, but presumably this
made a ton of environments.
Uh, not that bad. 8K environments. So,
yeah, this will run this exact thing
will run over 10 million steps per
second for training uh in Puffer 4.
And those 10 million SPS worth of
optimizations, those sure as [ __ ] were
not made by Opus. I can tell you that.
So
presumably I at least have
some ability to assess whether these
things are good or not, you know, where
Optim mostly the whole thing, dude,
like it's an entire C++ backend with
custom photographing and several custom
kernels and a new architecture. uh a
fundamentally new architecture as well.
It's everything.
Did it all happen? No, the environment
is still on CPU and we're going to get
10 million steps per second with the
envon CPU.
You can easily like plug in a GPU
environment though. Is it really? It is
really No, actually it's not, man. We
basically we killed off most of the GPU
CPU transfer overhead. That was one of
the major innovations.
It's actually with the new architecture,
there's even less reason to do stuff on
CUDA.
It's um it's like asynchronous buffered
host device transfers. Yeah, for you
obviously you need it for physics,
right? But for like most environments
that are clearly intended to be run on
CPU, there's not going to be a reason to
port them to GPU just so that you don't
have the device transfer.
damage taken.
Damage dealt.
Can we just I think we can just put this
on one B now, right?
Let me go get wand. So, I was using
Neptune, but like literally in the time
that I've um
Is actually is Neptune still alive? Cuz
it would be nice to just be able to use
Neptune still for
Okay, it's shutting down in March, so
it's still alive for a bit.
Free key. You can log stuff if you want.
I guess.
Are we RL patchwork rotations or what?
Wait, are we RLing patchwork rotations
or what is puffer raid?
Uh, so this is it's the great M fight
from old school is the sim we're working
on.
Well, not really working on. This is the
test I'm using for Opus, right?
Uh, okay. Well, something went insane
here because this number doesn't make
any sense to me.
So, we'll see what's going on.
I get flashbacks every time I see old
school. Yeah. You and me both.
You tested Puffer 30 on Nvidia driver
590. Got a weird bug with Muan from
Heavy Ball. Uh, I haven't tested it on
590.
There are versions of Heavy Ball that
error out though. If you'd like, you can
go steal our Muan implementation from
Puffer 4. I have an implementation of
Muon that's like a 100 lines and exactly
matches Heavy Ball.
move to puffer. No, you shouldn't, dude.
It's not stable. It's not remotely
stable.
Like, it's not even pre-release stable
yet, dude. It's going to take me time.
It's hard. Like, puffer 4 makes
everything else I've ever done look like
Child's Play.
So, I don't know what the heck is going
on with these stats.
Um,
this looks good.
I have no idea what this has done. Let's
go see.
What did I just call this?
Oh,
I have no idea where I just copied that
to.
did. We're going to see if it's any
good. That's the point of the stream is
everybody's asking me to test been
asking me to do a stream testing the
models heavily. So today,
uh, let's see. So, okay, there's our
model.
550 KB is Oh, no. That's actually the
right size. Our models are tiny.
Yeah, it's actually the right size,
funny enough.
Okay.
Can you actually Let me see if I
actually have this working. Okay. Yeah,
it does work. So we can actually run
this
upper raid
fired keyword are numbers
really
Uh, does this experience make you more
confused?
I get some of it, but there's some stuff
that's like weird. What do you think of
CS as a major? A lot of push pushing
people away from it. So, a lot of noise
is what there is.
I mean, honestly, the best reason to not
do CS nowadays is because you just do
not want to spend your time around these
Hollywood tech wannabes.
Numbles.
Hang on. I'm just trying to figure out
what it did because it shouldn't have
Oh, wait. Config.
Oops.
Crap.
Okay. So, it's Is it grabbing the wrong
file?
programming is headache.
Well, it doesn't stop. But the thing is
like it's kind of beside the point.
Okay, so this is what's happening here,
right?
Pie torch. Uh, what's the easiest way
for me to fix this
version mismatches?
Can I just install the CPU version real
quick?
I had this local thing I didn't have
time to fix.
This is why I always do everything in
Docker, by the way.
How's the model so far? It's doing some
stuff.
I mean, it's really like the last 10 20%
is the the thing that matters though.
It's like how much of a mess we have to
deal with.
Why did I start puffer? Because I wanted
to actually make RL work.
Cuda. Yes, this is the annoying thing. I
think I can just do
by CPU and we should be able to get a
quick U val, right? Yeah, there we go.
Okay. Um,
let's slow it down. But, uh, that to me
looks like a, uh, a model that we
trained on our first try.
I'm trying to think how we fix that.
Actually
We'll do that.
Is this stream on YouTube? Yeah,
it's at uh what what's my handle?
Somebody give it to him. Is it I think
it's KSRS 5341 still there. I'll be
right back and we'll see. I think we
actually have a trained model first try.
So, we'll see.
Can you not do RL in any big? No company
has done what I've done with Puffer,
man. Not close to it.
Hang on.
Initial environment seems working.
Let's see what our model does.
It's a very very simple environment
actually right now without the specials
and stuff in and also I think there's a
lot of leniency the mechanics
Well, the SIM is way too lenient.
It's uh you see like it's it's switching
sides
like way too easily.
So, the RL agent is good. The SIM is
bad.
adversarial selfplay.
Uh, that's still in development.
Is it not going to kill the hands at the
same time?
Oh, that's not good. Oh, but it's not
being uh it's not being punished for
doing that. I see.
Tricky to update.
Uh there's algorithmic shenanigans that
goes on.
Okay. So it's learned the thing. It's
being incentivized wrong and their
problems with this. So now this is the
question folks, right? So like what do
you do? We have a this is actually the
really good question. Okay. So we have a
uh probably 80% of the way there sim
right in the sense that it has the basic
structure. We have an agent that learns
on it. Um but there are a bunch of bugs.
It doesn't it's not really set up the
way that it should. And now I have
what thousand lines?
Yeah. little over a thousand lines worth
of code uh that I have not read once
and that we need to fix all the the main
things with.
Yeah.
And it's basically now it has left me
with the 20% like worst part which is
the reason that nobody finishes their
projects.
What's going on with Opus? No, this is
not playing against Opus. We are we
trained this model. The model that you
just saw playing the game was one that I
just trained in 1 minute on one GPU.
That's puffer lip
exactly. So what do I do here? Right. Do
I just like keep telling Opus to fix the
things and trying to figure out from
that? Do I start trying to read the
code? What do I do?
in which I've not read once. I I asked
everybody on the stream how I should do
this at the start and it was like
overwhelmingly
people said that I should just like let
the model do the stuff at least to start
with. So this recommendation came
straight from you guys. So I'm not
taking the blame for that.
All the things you just told us, you
should have told coll.
So you're basically saying that I should
outsource all possible thinking. I've
I've done zero thinking today, but like
I should outsource it even more.
Opus loop be precise.
What's happening with binary search?
Learn to code maybe
dark. I do know how to like go check
puffer. That's all written by hand.
The point of this stream is that I like
people wanted to specifically see me try
this stuff because I do always do
everything by hand.
Depends if you want opus to fix use opus
to fix it. Claude did it. I think we're
at the point where we look at the code
outsource all possible thinking is that
guy literally designed for that.
Hope is to point out where it thinks the
issues are.
Get commit. We have We have a commit.
Highlight your issues. Now, go back
100% no thinking.
Race failure modes
and time.
the same point trying to write a single
line of code myself
keep iterating but eventually I think
you're stuck reading the code
prototype done fix the code okay so
we'll try to get to fix a little bit um
Let's actually do one change at a time.
We're going to do this one first.
What happened to the guys working on the
drums in the UK? Uh, I sent them two
drones. They're still working on it and
we're hiring one of them as an intern
for the summer. So, pretty good. They're
doing cool stuff.
copy paste your guides into Claude.
That's funny.
It's actually kind of funny. This works
better than I expected and somehow feels
even worse than I expected. So, it's
like it surpassed expectations in both
directions.
UK guys have Twitter, I think. So, yeah,
if you check any of the drone tweets,
negative one reward clamping. I have to
double check the the magnitudes.
get good outputs without priming the
context?
Still knowing every line in the repo.
This is a massive shift. Yeah, this
feels awful.
Um,
the one thing I will say is I don't
consider this to be expensive. Like
I do not consider this to be expensive
if it works. Like that's not the
complaint I have. We have, let me
refresh.
Reward 5.0. You know,
it's fine. It'll just get uh it'll like
it'll get clamped. Whatever.
Yeah, I'll actually But I'll tell it to
just do it
clamped.
Yeah, because that actually wouldn't
scale it correctly.
25 worth it. Um, so the thing is
like if this thing could just produce uh
a medium complexity environment like in
a day without like and just have it be
easy that would worth that would be
worth many thousand.
Um the problem is like it
it's not exactly what we're seeing here,
right? It's like good in some ways and
going to be very iffy in others.
Like 80% complete projects are not
really worth anything.
So like this is why I say like I can't
tell you guys if it's good or not until
the project is done because I get so
many 80% complete projects PR and like
that's just not worth anything, right?
It has to be done.
reason about the state space volume. Not
exactly, Burns.
But like, dude, if I paste,
it's just going to eat the whole context
and I'm going to have to recompress. No,
like I'm not on refactoring right now,
Jess. Like, I'm not having it refactor
for code quality yet. I'm like having it
fix dynamics.
I've already had to compress twice
convert. So it it does eat through it.
I will do it just but I don't think yet
right
like not yet right
rewards. Yeah, but that's super easy to
fix. Like that the thing missing little
things like that. That's not that's not
the main issue.
Let's get this thing trained again if we
can.
Huh. Missing token.
And gave it the token already.
Okay. So, here we're training it again
and uh we'll see what this does.
frustrating about not using the LMS
further behind
in good viewpoint. That's kind of the
idea, right?
I mean, the thing is that this just
feels so incredibly stupid that like
doing work in the way that I'm saying
here, it's like recommending people do
this to me feels like recommending
people just go jump out the nearest
window.
It's like a complete destruction of um
human intellect.
So I like I don't know. I'm going to
have to think about it.
It seems to me though like the models
have gotten very better but like have
gotten a lot better but they're being
deployed in like the laziest
uh like the laziest and most actually
mythanthropic way possible which is of
course companies always become the
opposite of what they're named. So
hopefully we don't become deflated AI.
Did episode length just go down
dramatically
with 1.0 ohm kills? I think it did. I
think that's actually a good solve.
It's closer.
Let's watch it do the fight.
It's actually kind of funny that this
thing is doing um this is like not that
far off from a strategy that you can do
managers.
No,
I sure as hell hope not. I mean, I guess
it makes sense because the managers are
already basically worthless,
full review of Tiny Brad. It is, man.
It's just so I've had so much work on
Puffer 4. Um, and like the thing with
Tiny Brad is they have it's just it's
harder to integrate than I thought it
was going to be. So that means it's
harder for me to test as well.
what's hard integration wise. So, uh
they generate variably shaped kernels
that are absolutely not supposed to be
looked at manually or fixed shaped
kernels rather. You can get them to
generate variable shaped kernels, but
then they're very slow.
So, like they actually do have good
kernel gen, but I haven't found good
kernel gen for the case that I have. And
it's it's like a very different workflow
they expect. They basically expect you
to not actually look at the kernels.
What's the point of new environments?
How do you think we get our research
done?
Test agent capabilities exposes flaws.
We use them in the like in an
interactive loop in the process of
developing new algorithms.
Don't mage it. Okay, good. See, look. It
knows not to mage. Oh,
that's sketchy.
That's sketchy.
Is it going to be able to do it?
Uh, I think it just accidentally screwed
it up. I think it just screwed itself.
Nope. Yeah, it just screwed itself. Just
barely.
Yeah, it's so it's not a perfect agent.
It got very very close.
Yeah, you can't actually test it on
Atari is the problem. Atari is too slow.
Yeah, if I could train on Atari at 5
million steps per second, then that
would be awesome.
Can we speed up the sim? Yeah, we can
totally speed up the sim.
I was kind of just watching it to see if
I could
You can't, man.
You can write it native, but you can't
write a 5 mil emulator.
So, we do have native games, right? But
you can't make the emulator 5 mil.
That's the problem.
It's doing advanced training runs. No,
I'm doing the I'm doing training runs
out of the box. That's just pufferly
being good at training though and it not
being that hard yet.
Admittedly, it's nice that it didn't
mess up the ops or anything.
making it native.
Uh that it has to be able to
autonomously re-implement and check the
environments.
Okay, look. See, it got the head.
This is the head phase. That's like not
that far off of how the actual fight
looks.
Isn't that what our friend flood code is
doing right now?
Kind of.
Like the thing is this is 80% done, man.
This is like an 80% end.
I'm trying to think what I do to like
see if it can get the last 20% though,
right?
Well, it's also it's 80% of the simple
ends, right? Like there's quite a bit.
Like the actual fight has a lot of stuff
in it additionally.
But as I said, if I can just get the
simple chunk of it working, that's still
pretty good.
Any time saved by getting it. Well, the
problem is that 80% done is not useful
really, right?
I think the first thing that I would
like to have is I would like to get the
I'd like to have the attack mechanic
match the real game a fair bit closer
right here and then maybe we think about
if we want to implement specials and
other stuff.
Yes, the the thing is it trained out of
the box on first try. So this is a brand
new environment that Puffer Lib has
never seen before and I just copied some
default parameters
and it trained first try
and then I added one additional reward
and it trained um and it like trained
substantially better.
That is buffer lift.
[snorts]
What's the agent trying to do? kill the
boss. So the bos this is the great M
fight from Runescape. Um
a simplified version of it. So there are
two hams that have to be defeated at the
same time and then the head becomes
vulnerable and then you have to hit it.
And there's also this strafing thing
where like it's too lenient right now so
you can't see it well but there's this
like strafing pattern that you have to
do otherwise you get hit.
See, like uh see it screwed up right
there. It killed the hand too fast, so
it healed
Can I write simulation in any language?
You can write a simulation in any
language, but our bindings are for C
because if you try to write an
environment in Python, it'll be slow.
We train at millions of steps per
second.
You know, puffer lib is very very high
perf by design.
Okay. So, I think that what we need to
do, what is it? It is 235.
Why don't we spend a little bit of time
actually researching the correct turning
mechanic here so we get something that
looks much more like the real fight and
then we'll think if we do specials and
other stuff with this as well.
I think if I at least have the full like
turning thing done
then at least that'll be cool because
then we can also try multi- aent and
stuff.
How many M's in parallel? Like 8 uh
8,000
custom driver to avoid moving between
GPUs and CPU as long as you match
inference. It will worse. Yeah, you have
to match the interface. Yeah,
we did actually substantially fix that
overhead though uh in the new update.
So,
okay. So, hang on. I'm trying to think
how we can do this. I literally I can't
even like log in and do this cuz this
boss is at the end of the raid.
[laughter] I have not played that game
in like three years. Um, so I probably
couldn't even get to the end of the raid
quickly if I wanted to.
Web search.
Okay.
assume Claude can write a 100% nicely
written end code. Could it develop
something like Puffer Lib?
Uh, if you can develop something like
Puffer LIIB, then you should be able to
just revolutionize whatever the hell you
want overnight. So,
I mean, this is why I like I'm so
suspicious about these things, right?
Because the value of getting a project
80% of the way there versus getting a
project like really good, most of the
work is in that last 20%.
So, you know, models getting stuff 80%
of the way there is like a lot of junior
projects, right, will get 80% of the way
there.
Being able to actually produce something
that is correct and good and polished is
substantially harder.
Oh yeah, there's actually there is a
task in Runescape for the perfect M solo
which like requires you never get hit or
whatever. I'm trying to think. I think
I've done that task actually. I'm pretty
sure I've done that task.
It turns out like they kind of
intentionally design stuff so you can
avoid all damage most of the time, but
it's like very difficult.
Um, I mean I would like So the thing is
the stuff that he's talking about is
pretty reasonably within the realm of
what you can do when you bind to puffer,
right?
So four to one and three to zero are not
going to work. Those are techniques that
would require
there's other stuff that we'd have to
implement before those would work.
Yeah, this is like a Yeah, that makes
sense.
The thing is I can actually Train junior
devs to finish projects very quickly if
they're smart.
See it like it actually did get this
wrong now.
I'm definitely impressed in one sense.
It's like both better and worse than I
expected.
It is kind of like suggesting somebody
jump out a window though in the sense
that like there's zero thinking going on
here. Absolutely zero.
So if intellectual work is core to your
identity in any substantial way like
you see what I mean?
Yeah. There's also zero learning. I'm
learning absolutely nothing uh while
doing this. So,
it's like just
it's like a very antihuman
implementation of this
solving less steps. Yeah. So Tim, that's
pretty much what we did with Puffer.
God damn it. This is probably going to
make me download the game if I want to
finish this environment, isn't it?
I'm going to actually have to go
download the game, make like 200
potions, and then sit in that boss room
for an hour and make notes to actually
get the uh the the tile cycles correct,
most likely
Perfect. I'm pretty sure I've literally
done that achievement major.
It's very hard.
[clears throat]
sometimes crit and they it's usually a
mess.
Has a tick engine? Yes.
So, yes, it's the same thing. It's
animation smoothed under the hood.
Uh here, I'll show you. Can you check
achievements like that?
There you go. I thought it Oh, it's 700
total. It's 400 of chambers there.
combat record.
I didn't think you could check.
Like the thing that's obnoxious about
this to me as well is like technically
this consumes no energy on my part. So I
could probably just sit here and do this
type of stuff 18 hours a day because it
requires no thinking. But then like when
I actually have to go and think about
stuff, I actually have to be properly
fresh, right? Like thinking is hard.
Building [clears throat] the stuff
manually is hard. Um
but then if you're not thinking about
stuff,
I don't know. It's just a very bad
dynamic.
end up slopping things up. But
literally, there's no thinking required
for this at all.
Like, compared to what I'm used to
actually implementing this stuff
manually, this doesn't require anything.
It's like no wonder people like this.
It's because you can AFK your job,
right?
You just don't think and you AFK your
whole job.
No, I don't think this is how old
programmers felt about compilers.
Yeah. The thing is that like what makes
puffer lip good is the amount of thought
like that's been put into every little
thing in it. Like I stack up a lot. You
can't do that while not like thinking
about
it's just like
dynamic sucks, man.
This dynamic really sucks.
You can't even get Super Maven anymore
is the thing.
Cursor bought it and they're only
supporting um existing users.
buying up good [ __ ] and shutting it
down. Yeah, exactly.
Pop up your level abstraction. No, I
don't think so. Good stuff is made by
going lower level than everyone else is
worth like is willing to
No, I don't think that taste is the
cope, man. There's zero value to it.
Like actually the stuff like the way
that stuff needs to be built is actually
pretty objective and clear. It just it
requires a lot a lot of very precise
understanding of many things that most
people are not willing to look into.
Like for instance, how did I get RL up
to 10 million steps per second, right?
Like 9 million. We're going to have 10
by the release. Um,
it was a lot of very precise fiddling
with things that are completely
undocumented and like there being five
different ways that I could possibly do
it and testing every single one of them,
right? Like it's completely opposite
from what I'm doing here. There'll be a
recording of this. Yeah, it's on uh all
my streams are uh VA archived to
YouTube.
Strong suit. Yeah. And honestly, like I
[ __ ] hate this timeline. That's
probably going to be the title of the
article because like yes, the models are
getting better and we're using them to
like to do the intellectual equivalent
of just jumping out the nearest window.
Like honestly, this timeline just
[ __ ] sucks.
So apparently it can't get clicking to
work.
Well, this is kind of what I was afraid
of with the 80% thing.
Let's see if we can fix this.
generally happy for anthropic winning
over open AAI. No man, the anthropic
people were like the batshit insane
people who left Open AI who were like
completely out of touch with the world.
underestimating how simple some of the
stuff people working on is.
Overestimating how bad people were at
coding.
Most people weren't doing anything
interesting to begin with. Yeah, but I
don't care about that. Trying to do
something, but they're not like they're
trying to do something interesting while
learning nothing. You learn absolutely
nothing while doing this.
No, there's not. I'm not going to accept
the like, oh, this model is a joke
compared to this other model that came
out this past month. Like, I asked a
bunch of people. They told me to do
Opus. It's like, oh, this would have
worked with GPT5. No, I'm not dealing
with that.
I said I will entertain a reasonable
criticism. I pulled this a ton
um before I did this frame and we said
that it was going to be opus
Yeah, we can probably load some
sequences in, but like we actually have
to get the mechanics design defined
precisely to do that.
Like there's a reason it's very
difficult to write good unit tests in
games
through the repo. See, I wouldn't
recommend you do that winner. Like I
have a guide where the material there
will actually be correct that I spent a
lot of time on.
Like honestly, some of the comments I'm
seeing here in this stream are more
depressing than like working on uh
fixing shitty CUDA bugs for 12 straight
hours.
I don't like fixing CUDA. I [ __ ] hate
fixing CUDA bugs. And actually, it's not
even CUDA bugs. It's mostly torch bugs
by the uh introduced by meta engineers
doing dumb [ __ ]
Like see the world that I would like in
the world that I would like right we
have good software that you can read and
understand that is actually
well-designed and compact and fast and
this makes it easier to write other good
software around it that is small and
compact and fast
and I would like AI to help us do that
rather than the opposite where you're
just blowing up massive amounts of
garbage.
Okay. If I'm not familiar with the
tools, then like I literally have I
still have 80 plus people here. Um, like
go on. What am I doing wrong with it?
Right.
Why do you think Opus has gotten the
attention? because of the car path you
tweet.
You're right. This is basically how I
use it. See,
it's also why I can tweet so much. Yeah,
no [ __ ] If this is what work is, I
could just be playing games or doing
whatever all day. [ __ ] I could do this
blackout drunk and it wouldn't make a
difference. There's literally zero
thinking going on whatsoever here.
It would probably be a lot more fun as
well.
You don't need to be working on six
projects at a time though, dude.
The problem that we have is not that
people can't work on six projects at a
time. It's the problem that like the
problem we has is basically nobody
almost nobody ever builds anything of
substantial value. Like there are so few
projects that are actually good and one
good project is so incredibly valuable
and so incredibly broadly useful, but
nobody ever built anything [ __ ] good.
Everybody just built [ __ ] That's the
problem. So spinning up six instances
doesn't fix that.
See? Yeah. See,
why you say anthropic people are so
crazy? Um
cuz I was there at Open AI when like the
people like I saw the type of people
that split off and I've talked to many
of them in SF and they are insane.
They have a lot of just straight up
mental patients.
I don't know what to tell you.
Yeah, exactly. Context switching around
six things is not good either.
What is thinking according to how do you
define it? That's irrelevant. It's
definitely not this and it's definitely
is present in some of the other stuff I
have to do, right?
I don't have to have a precise
definition for it to be a useful
concept. And uh generally find trying to
put a precise definition of stuff like
that will not be helpful to you.
Okay, this is correct path finding
behavior. All right.
Okay. Okay, this is actually almost to
the point that I can test the correct
mechanic.
So, the way that this is supposed to
work,
um, it's the way that this is supposed
to work in this fight is you start, I
believe it's this tile here or this tile
here. You hit this so that you get
dragged over. You continue running until
you get to the tile that turns the head
and then you run back.
And then you hit one more time in the
middle
like that's there's a precise cycle.
Let me go see if I can just add
indicators to it.
It might be this one. Whoops.
Yeah. Let's see. Oh, this is different
because this is not a solo.
Okay. So, this is what's this?
This one.
Six.
Uh, is this the right tile?
No, that's the ring tile.
Sorry, I haven't done this fight in like
three years, guys. I've done it like
Let me see where it is.
I'm trying to remember which is the mage
tile.
Stand here for Oh, here it is. Yeah,
it's this image is the one that we want.
No, this is thumb
long range and standing on these. Okay,
here it is. Yeah, here it is.
M maging from the melee hand. You'll
need Yeah. Okay, this this one. Okay.
Uh do you think it's good enough for you
to try? The model is better than
expected, but the
uh the like the form factor, so to
speak, the work loop of it is awful.
Like awful. Awful. Awful.
It's not going to know from the pick cuz
you guys don't know what I'm talking
about from the picture.
Six.
Did I count wrong?
4 hours. No, five and 5 hours 20 minutes
so far
times. It's 3:20.
I'll go until at least 5.
And we should at least get a prototype
of this today.
One, two,
three,
five. Piles
Current opinion success. Uh mixed
mixed for sure.
Naive approach complexity flaps. What do
you mean complexity flaps? What's that
mean?
Give it the pick. tell to draw you a
grid on it. The grid is kind of
deceptive is the thing in this game.
Like there is an actual grid under the
hood.
10.
So, it's it is 19 tiles, I believe.
Then, how do I do it wrong if it's 19
tiles?
Anything complex without the little?
No, that's that's cap. That's [ __ ]
Okay. And then the center one. Was it
one, two, three before you're standing
in front? So, one, two, three.
I don't think you nailed the scope. So
slugging it out. Obi-Wan, I asked the
entire chat. I was going to keep writing
the spec, okay? And the entire chat
said, "Oh, no. you know, this is the
point at which I would start doing stuff
with Claude.
Okay, so I'm not taking that as a
response when the entire chat, including
the people who have been asking me to do
this and telling me that the models were
so good and make them so productive,
told me to do it in exactly this way.
chat. Don't know. Got to think for
yourself. Isn't that ironic to talk
about thinking for yourself on this
stream? There is no thinking at all this
stream. Zero.
I think this is it on the thumb. Can you
hit from here? I think you can.
So I think
you're not in the vibe. I am iterating,
dude. What I'm doing right now is I'm
trying to figure out the exact mechanic.
Like right now it's there's a very
precise number of tiles I'm trying to
figure out. Uh like the only other way I
could figure this out. Look, if
anybody's in game right now at the you
can go ahead and like help me count some
tiles, but otherwise there's no way I
can do this other than looking at this
and figuring it out from here.
I haven't logged into that game in like
three years, so excuse me if I forget a
little bit.
I might be able to get it from a video.
Hang on. I might be able to count from a
video though.
Claude takes images.
It's not just like an images thing,
dude. If I give you the image, you can't
tell either.
Okay, I think I can do
this.
Okay, look there. I can get it from
One, two, three, four, five, six. Yeah.
One, two,
two, three, four, five, six, seven,
eight. Eight tiles. Okay. So, I'm off by
Yeah, that's why. So, it's only 17
tiles.
I should only make the front row. It
should be 17 tiles wide. Okay. So, let
me fix this.
Runarkers.net/home.
This the mage tile here or is this the
telly tile?
I can't tell until I unless I look at it
like this
or is it No, it is from this tile that
you attack, right?
Oh, okay. I see. So, yeah. Hang on. We
can do it like this.
Get tiles data. Does it have it
annotated or something?
One, two. Okay. Look. One, two, three,
four, five.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven,
eight, nine.
Okay.
11 12 13 14 15
Is it 16 tiles?
That seems weird.
Seven. Let's make it. All right.
Whatever. Let's do Okay. Change to 15
tiles
wide.
Six. Seven. Okay.
Marker
one from
right.
And I swear if this if this stream gets
me to log into this absolute heroine
game, like God, I'm like three years
clean of this game. Okay.
and gradually disempowered.
Yeah, I think that's the bad timeline,
right? is that we continue designing
these tools in a way that like
just encourage people to be lazy and
stupid and then we continue to build
like huge amounts of bloated lazy dumb
things
and then we don't actually get like the
awesome future that we want because all
the like it's just built on duct tape
garbage.
Well, that's language gap, man. 1,700.
Like, that's language gap.
Reream. Porky.
Reream.
Uh, let's see. One,
two, three, four, five, six,
eight.
Sad truth is most software is built on
garbage software. Yeah, but like you're
not going to get me excited by saying
here you can ship more garbage, right?
So, it's supposed to be I think from
here to here.
One, two, three, four.
It's so funny that you think that way,
Dark. It's like,
do you really just want to live in a
world where nobody thinks at all?
We just all go be back go back to being
apes. That's cool. you know,
it's not really a species worth
preserving at that point, which is
entirely [ __ ] depressing given all
the awesome [ __ ] we've done. But, you
know, you can think that way if you
want.
I can't think of a more heinous
worldview than that, but go ahead.
miss it.
One, two. It's seven tiles. It is seven
tiles. Okay. So, it's one, two, three,
four, five, six. Yeah, that's the
correct cycle.
Don't believe the cloud code is now
written with claw code. That's not what
I'm saying.
This is the most depressing piece of
software I've used. like ever. So I like
I can't think of a piece of software
that's made me feel worse using it than
this. So that's not the point,
right?
Yeah. Okay. So I think now this is this
is the correct layout,
but it needs the tile turning.
Yeah. The thing, Peter, is that the way
that the interface is set up, it is set
up to replace thinking.
Okay. Why is the head not? What the
[ __ ]
Yeah, tax.
Uh, hang on.
It's I don't I can't tell if it's quite
there.
Well, it doesn't turn the mage head,
right? I mean, it doesn't turn the head.
Let me see if I was doing this right.
It's hit there, right? And then it's hit
there. What tile do you actually stand
on when you're hitting?
I'm trying to match the dynamics exactly
because this is one of those things
where you actually have to match the
exam the dynamics very precisely.
Okay, it is hit on this tile
and then hit there. Okay, cool. So,
yeah. So, the head turning behavior is
wrong. Okay, that's what it is. It's the
head turning behavior is wrong.
Uh, can I still do it though if I'm
careful? I think
article. Yeah, that's mostly what I'm
doing.
How to use this and still think. I don't
think there is a way. That's the
problem. It's designed to make you not
like it's an interface thing.
Actually, this might be enough though to
do something interesting, right?
Let me see.
Well, I I guess you know, one cool thing
about having the best RL library out
there is we can just kind of try to RL
it and see what it learns
because I'm sure that it'll be able to
play better than I have than I can.
Okay, we do this. We're good.
We uh
engineers
using the software. Yeah, there's a lot
of stuff.
Okay, let's train this model. Let's see
if it does anything. I'll be right back.
And who wants hears your arguing?
Thinking still matters.
Yeah,
but that's like that's just the end of
the human species is what that is. So
like if that's your answer. Okay.
Uh this does learn
No, the state of software is is like
worse now than it was in the 2000s.
at least use. Okay. So, see I just like
you're incapable of thought, my friend.
Nothing personal. You're incapable of
thought.
No wonder you like these tools.
This is the thing that's just like
bothering the crap out of me. It's like
I have one file. I have one file. The
editor makes a difference. Really?
Really?
Like look, it would be one thing if like
car pathy came in here and told me this.
Like have you built anything useful?
You're not
the heck? They're not rebuilt. What' I
do?
The thing is it's like not just writing
things by hand to learn like
The level at which the distinction
between good and bad software is made is
very low. It's a very low level at which
that distinction is made.
It's a level below like the entirety of
what is happening here.
Oops.
Can't even type my password after
staring at this for six hours.
Uh, I think I'm loading the wrong model
or something cuz this is not doing
anything.
It's actually I'm surprised that the
code is not as bad as I thought. Um,
but that doesn't it like I actually
thought that if the if it wrote code
that looked better that would make it
nicer, but it's actually It's now it's a
workflow problem more than anything.
Like you're basically just intended to
have this write the damn code for you.
And like [ __ ] off if you say otherwise
when anthropic employees are literally
tweeting that they don't ever write a
single line of mode.
I think it would probably have to be
something like
the model is a process that is watching
you as you code and is autonomously like
spinning off little tests and things and
alternatives uh as you're writing code
so that it like prevents you from
hitting as many bad like super obnoxious
just errors. You get a very lightweight
autocomplete
uh so that you're still thinking about
the code that you're writing, but you
basically just get to write the code.
you get to write the code at the speed
that you would if you never had to be
dealing with not like actual logic bugs,
but you know, both like the the quick
little bugs that you just fix
immediately because I messed this syntax
or that whatever, but then also like the
deep usage bugs where it's like, hey,
this library works this way. It's
completely undocumented
and like it's only available in these
five random repos online that happen to
be the LLM training code. Like I would
think that there's a way to do it
differently like that.
I think also like um writing throwaway
tests would also be fine
if the thing is not just writing the
test but also constantly assessing when
they're like if they're still relevant
or not. There's a lot you could do, but
it essentially, ironically enough,
designing that would require more
thought than designing something like
this that just removes human control
entirely. So, of course, it's it's kind
of ironic that this is the laziest
possible design for a tool that is
designed to make you as lazy as
possible.
Oh, I see the problem.
That's not literally cursor. That's not
cursor at all.
It's a pretty substantial program. I
mean, you can go see the number of
experienced devs I've seen screw these
things up leads me to believe that no,
these are actually pretty complex. And
like the thing is most actually complex
software is only complex because it's
designed terribly,
you know?
So, it's a different cycle than in the
real game, but look at that.
>> Yeah, that's the other thing, you know,
like
That's a pretty solid agent though,
right?
times. It's 400 p.m. Say we have an
hour, maybe a little more.
Trying to think if we can match the
exact cycle. That would be cool to do.
Design puffer. Well, yeah. No,
but like the thing is it's
I think people like like are approaching
this is from the perspective of like oh
programmers are worried they don't have
any value anymore. Like that's not it. I
can go do a bajillion other things with
my time, right?
Like I'm an MIT PhD. I've spent more
than half of my life devoted to getting
good at doing research and science. So
I'm not worried about not having a job.
That's not it. All right.
The thing is that to me this feels very
deeply fundamentally wrong in the sense
that it pushes us towards not thinking
about the things that we rely on in any
deep and meaningful way and that doesn't
seem good
right
thoughts on model based and behavior.
See, like Dreamer and Dreamer V3, they
look good on paper. Well, I haven't
checked V4. That's not RL. Um, but
Dreamer V3 does not work at all as it's
written on paper.
Okay. So, I mean, this does our version
of the M fight fully. I think that what
I'd like to do in the next hour is if we
can just exactly match the tick cycle so
that this basically feels like a full
simulator of the fight. That would be
pretty cool.
AJ, that's why I'm doing the stream.
I've been giving lots of thoughts. I'm
not going to just keep reiterating them.
Um, we're going to finish this and then
I'm going to have to go think and I'm
going to have to write an article of
some variety
about that regard without trying to
plot. No, I can't because it's the
specific form in which this is
implemented is even much worse than I
thought.
Uh this is the optimal tick cycle. I'm
pretty sure for uh this is the optimal
tick cycle. It doesn't matter that it's
taking this step. It's the same amount
of time. So for this version of the M,
this is optimal. So I we need to fix the
head turning though. So we'll do that
next.
None of non MIT world class researchers
are very concerned. So this is why I'm
streaming it, right?
Cuz I'm not. That's not even like a
concern. Duh.
This is much more about like what does
this imply for the future of software
and like
is this actually pushing us to a world
where things are better and faster and
more stable? Or is this pushing us to a
world where there's a lot of stuff out
there and stuff gets built really fast,
but nobody understands any of it and it
all sucks and nobody thinks and we like
lose all the core skills that were way
way more prevalent uh even in the '9s.
Yes.
Benjamin, I'm simultaneously like
impressed and disgusted.
Like at least change your name to
misanthropic because you obviously hate
humanity with the way that this is like
most anti-human design thing I could
possibly imagine.
I'm actually I am impressed by the
quality of the code but like the usage
and the intended loop with which you are
to interact with this is just awful.
First thought of exact was to replace
instead of augment plus they're [ __ ]
aren't that interesting and treated to
solve problems.
They're not though is the thing.
Like there are unsolved problems
everywhere.
Like literally just anywhere you look
or people who say they built useful
things with Opus. I don't know.
I don't know. I'm going to like I'm
going to get dinner after this and then
I'm going to have to think about some
stuff.
I wish I could remember how this
mechanic worked exactly so we could just
implement this thing and have the full
thing done. Um, this is just like a not
remembering how it works thing.
I think you do have to run back farther.
You have to run back to here, don't you?
expected intensity.
The expectations are non-existent, man.
Most developers produce nothing. Like
literally nothing.
The bar in my view is like it's you have
to dig for it.
I forgot that there's like actually not
docks on this.
I think I know the guide actually that
has it isn't well documented.
Okay, let me go find the actual guide
from this is original.
I think I can just find it in here. This
has the the actual mechanic documented
if it adds.
Um,
okay. This actually this has it
documented somewhere here.
Uh, 23.
Where's the Where's the thing?
Where's CC
settings?
Huh? You work where closed captions?
Is that it?
No.
Where did the closed captions button go?
The heck?
Yeah, I got contacts.
M turns every port. Yeah, it does. Then
there's a mechanic. Basically, I'm just
trying to match the last mechanic.
There's this mechanic where if you hit
if you actually hit it correctly, it
always turns. Um, but then it has a
chance to not turn and it actually makes
the fight much more interesting.
I
think that the message I'm going to
have is still ultimately going to be the
same, which is try to learn and
understand things. And if you're going
to use these part these models, make
them a make them help you towards that
and not replace it. We'll see.
Um, actually, where's the closed
captioning on this? Does anybody know
what the heck happened to YouTube? Like
why don't I have the close captioning
option?
There it is. Unavailable. Oh, great.
That's why
here. Let me just see if I can figure
this out.
Hang on. There's one trick I have to
figure out and then we'll be good.
Oh, that's so weird.
If you get an XP drop here on this side,
then it turns.
That's super weird.
I don't even know how the heck that's
possible. I was afraid it was going to
be that. So, let me explain this on our
sim here.
Oops.
So,
if you are on this tile
and
you attack here and you hit because you
have a chance to miss. If you hit, then
the head always turns to this side.
I actually don't even know how you
implement that cuz like I don't even
know what the underlying code would be
to implement that.
Let's ask Claude
to
since today is the non-thinking
esoteric the stream has become. Well, I
figured that this would be a good
candidate for it. Just like it's an RL,
it's standalone. It's on like a kind of
a complicated sim that's more
complicated than it looks, but like I
know a lot about how this particular one
works and it's really cool when you get
it right, you know?
Does anybody like can anybody reverse
engineer how the heck that would
possibly make sense?
I don't understand how it would be that
if you get a if you hit it
taking damage and reading you on that
tile.
It's something to do with him taking
damage
where you were when he received damage.
when you were when he received damage.
If he doesn't receive damage, it's just
where you are.
need to track the position, not the
current pause. I It's something like so
it's it's basically if you're on one
side and you hit the other hand and then
you run to the middle, it turns all the
way over. Whereas if you don't hit the
hand and you run to the middle, it can
turn to the middle or it can turn to the
other side.
I forgot that this wasn't fully
documented.
I for I totally forgot that this chunk
was not fully documented. Runescape end.
Well, this is the only fight, right?
Liberty.
This is one of the best known fights
from the game.
Oh, wait, wait, wait. Here. Hang on.
Look. I found this.
This is good. Somebody linked this to me
before and I didn't know that this chunk
was in here.
One and eight will always force the head
to turn. Okay, here. Let's see if we can
figure this out, folks. Anybody can help
with this. This is like actually not
that crazy. I think we should get it
from this.
So, one and eight. So here's this the
labels right. So this is one and eight.
Okay. Yeah. So this is the mage hand
side. One and eight will always force
head to turn right.
How have you built an RL out in RL world
school is the game? So I don't have a I
don't have an environment for the full
game, right? I have some MMO
environments that are based on some of
the mechanics that I've used for
research. And now this is just a sim of
one fight. And it's actually not even
the full fight because we haven't
implemented any of the special attacks,
but it has like the the really core
interesting mechanic of this fight is
the way that the head turns creates
these really interesting cycles in how
you have to move and attack. It's very,
very unique and it's visually very
obvious when you see it, which is why I
thought this would be cool.
It's got like this type of a cycle
where, you know, you repeat this thing
in a loop except sometimes something can
happen and you do a different loop or
like some other thing can happen and you
do a different loop. It's like a bunch
of these like loops of perfect gameplay
actions put together and then if you
make a mistake, you have to get back
into the loop. It's It's very
interesting
checking in after getting stuff done. We
have a decent prototype.
Could be the tick. I think it's since
the last time
do you throw a model in one of the mini
sims and bootstrap from nothing? Yes,
exactly, Coyote. So, my main work is on
Puffer Lib. I build the fastest
reinforcement learning library for very
small models. So, uh, when I run, for
instance, this model that I've been
training on this, I train it in one
minute, but it runs 500 million ticks of
the game. So, you can go do the math on
that. It's some like utterly ludicrous
amount. It's probably like years worth
of data. It's a stupid stupid amount of
data that it plays on, but it's really
fast, so who cares, right? Also, yes,
thank you for reminding me. If you've
enjoyed uh seeing me suffer through all
this all day, folks, um yeah, star
puffer li on GitHub. Let me link it real
quick. It actually really helps me when
people start this. It's all open source
and uh there you go.
Yeah. Let me see if it looks right when
we uh when we run it. Okay.
Oh yeah. How much how much have we spent
in tokens? I wonder.
Last time I checked was this and now it
is
4150.
Final verdict is complicated.
There will be an article
on X.
Oh, okay. So, this is not going to Yeah,
this is not going to play.
correctly.
80% yet. Um,
questionable
one x for every turn. 10 line of code
for one.
debug a poor problem in puffer.
So that is just going to screw up my
code base for sure.
Do you like no code? No. This has been
the B like this basically this has been
like there's been no enjoyment out of
this whatsoever.
So I don't know you're going to get
there will be a take on this like some
of the stuff is better than expected.
The interface is worse than expected.
I think it's still checking the wrong
tile.
Huh?
Yo, you going to hit me?
Buggy ass sim much.
You seem more depressed today? Yes, cuz
this is completely depressing.
Yeah, this is more depressing than cuda
bugs
because the thing with the cuda bugs is
like I can eventually work around that
and like get puffer to a spot where I'm
not dealing with horrible ridiculous
[ __ ] but this is just like horrible
ridiculous [ __ ] incarnate.
Okay. Do we get hit here? Yes. Do we
turn
the head turn? Oops.
The head does turn
and I get hit.
Uh, the head should turn if you're
there.
Oh, yeah. He has them right here. Right.
Oops.
Is this and this much a prodev can do by
hitting by himself?
80 50 versus 80. Yeah, it's
I mean we'll see what we can get.
Like this feels awful though either way.
Like I'm going out for margaritas after
this cuz this just this was some
[ __ ]
This is way more depressing than
fighting cuda bugs all day.
Okay.
You turn.
Yes, you do turn.
This I think is correct. Hang on. Let me
see if it's correct. I like I know a few
cycles in here that are supposed to
work. So, let me see. I can test if it's
correct pretty easily.
That was weird.
Is it two ticks?
cycle's a little off.
New MS get added all once.
Yes, they do. That's how it works.
Actually, I can probably just get some
uh
I can probably just go find some old
school players to like help me figure
out if I can just get this to work like
cuz this is really close. So, here's
what we're going to do. Let's get
something trained.
release cycle is very long, like six
months. This one's actually longer cuz
four is a really hard update to do
It's no longer uh it's no longer
winning.
Well, I mean it depends if we're going
to say with no specials or not.
like the sim wise it's probably like 80
to 90% there but then I also have to go
look through all the code and stuff and
see if it's messed anything major up.
Yeah. So this is not solving the end
anymore which is weird.
Oh, I think it didn't learn to um
it didn't learn to stagger the hand
kills.
That's super weird.
All right. Is this the thing we got to
fix then before I finish streaming?
Yeah, I'm impressed and disgusted at the
same time, man.
I guess we may as well just copy the
policy to see what the heck
like what is it doing?
Huh?
Didn't we just say it fixed it?
Oh, it messed up.
Oh, okay. Cool. Yeah, that's fun.
So, what is it? Goes here and it does
this.
Yeah, there this it found an exploit
basically.
any of your clients gaming companies. Uh
we have some stuff lined up this coming
uh this year that we're looking at.
Can't give you details more than that,
but there's a lot you can do in gaming
of course with this And RL's pretty cool
because it can do stuff that you'll
basically never get out of any other
method.
It's like close, but the the problem
with it is it's close and I have no idea
how the hell it's implemented.
Ask it.
Find the vibe. Yeah, it's awful.
it's okay. I just want to get something
usable at least for now and then we can
we can at least uh I can figure out what
I want to do with this from here later.
I guess the one positive thing about
this is
if I were to consider this completely
separate from my normal work, it it
becomes substantially better, right?
Like if I go work on hard stuff that
needs a lot of thought
um like with my productive hours and
then like when I'm too tired to do other
stuff, I like fiddle with stuff like
this that it becomes substantially
better. But that still seems like a
really shitty use of these tools.
Oh, I'm still late.
Let me see. Is this correct now, though?
This might be just me not be having done
it in a long time.
I can't tell if it's very slightly off
still, but it's way closer.
Let's see what happens if I go train
this.
See,
we'll see if it finds something better
now.
Uh, the episode length going up is not
great.
Okay. So, somehow not great. Episode
return is okay.
At least the funny part how the RL is
quite stable. So, we can tell from that.
I bet you it's just killing the mage
hand on repeat.
It's probably what it's doing.
Maybe the melee cycle's messed up.
What's it doing?
Okay, it's going to turn the hand.
Oh,
That's actually pretty close to a strat
you can use. Nobody does this one in the
real game because it's way more clicks.
Okay, so then why is it never uh
winning?
I wonder if maybe I messed up the
headphase.
We'll watch it and we'll see.
D was really cool.
>> [laughter]
>> Oh yes, he killed the uh the mage hand
too early.
I think this should be the last run
hopefully.
Hopefully now it figures out how to
finish the fight.
I mean these params are like complete
random garbage.
All right, I got uh dinner at 6 and I
got to get there. So, finish this up. I
think we can hopefully get the model to
work properly.
What are the odds?
Oh, it almost got it right there. It was
fine for a second
and then it became unstable.
No, it's not 01 if boss is killed.
They're getting reward for damage and
there's a penalty for um killing a hand
while the other one has too much health
left. It's still a pretty simple reward
though. It's like the first thing I
tried with one mod one small
modification.
Why so high? Well, the optimizer is
different. It's muon. So, the uh it's
scaled differently. And then our mini
batch is also size 32,000. So,
it's different.
We might need to reduce it. I think that
the default is a little lower though.
Something's good. Some Something's
pretty good. Something's pretty bad.
We got to stagger the
No, it it staggers already. It's fine.
Hat. [clears throat]
Yeah, I think that we got to think about
the um reward a little bit.
Oh, this is um this is solved, isn't it?
60 mil.
Okay. So,
let's try this.
Okay, so let's see if this works.
Let's watch the raid, folks. Let's watch
the raid.
Could try multi- aent, too.
Be funny.
And probably do the same thing.
Oh yeah, you learn nothing by doing
this. You learn absolutely nothing.
That's for sure.
It's pretty close to the real fight. The
mechanics, I think, are slightly off,
but it's pretty close.
It's funny that it's learned it's
learned a strategy that's technically
valid, but no human player ever does
this because it's such a pain in the
ass.
pulling your hair out yet? I think I'm
going for margaritas is what I'm doing
after this.
It's pretty close.
I think that you can't not take damage
here, which should be fixed, but this is
pretty close.
It takes
humans 10 to 15 minutes. Uh, this does
not take humans 10 to 15 minutes to
learn how to play this. You watched me
try this for 10 to 15 minutes because
I've done the raid that this thing is
based off of for probably like 4 or 500
hours, dude.
I haven't done it in three years, but
still.
I died 25 times. Yeah, there you go.
[laughter]
I mean, it's also it's very easy without
all the special attacks and things. Um,
but yeah,
and also the actual machine training,
uh, it learned in like 20 seconds of GPU
time. It played it a lot of like a lot
longer in sim, but it's like 20 seconds
of GPU time. That's why RL is so cool.
Let me go get the screen recording of
this.
do that.
Yeah.
There we go. Uh yeah, for everybody
here, please do star puffer on GitHub.
It really does help me out a ton. It's
free. Uh all this stuff, this is all
free open- source work. Uh, I spend tons
and tons of time doing this and most of
what I stream is actually the nitty-g
gritties of technical dev and research
on building the fastest reinforcement
learning library in existence. Uh,
mostly the last few weeks it's been like
CUDA kernels and fighting PyTorch CUDAs
compatibility and custom model
architectures and heavy profiling. Lots
of really deep technical work. uh which
is of course going to be way slower than
stuff like this, but you do actually
really understand and learn and you're
able to build something that you're
truly proud of, which in this case I
have there's like no pride whatsoever
associated with this. I learned
basically nothing. So the model was
impressive in some ways, but I don't
know. There's also there's some stuff I
have thoughts. There will be a full
writeup. Um feed the puffer a star. I'm
getting drinks after this.
Thank you everyone.
And uh yeah,
that's about everything. I stream pretty
much all my devs, so I'm live most of
the time. Um five, six days a week
typically.